Welcome everybody.
We are back the h three podcast,
episode 100.
I got to tell you,
I wasn't sure we'd make it to 100.
We had a bumpy road.
We had some ups,
we had some downs.
We have some goose,
we have some laughs,
we had some booths,
but here we are for better or worse
episode for better 100.
Here we are.
We soldiered on.
First of all,
thank you to our sponsors,
stamps.com.
Me undies 23.
Me Twenty three and me and dollar shave
club now.
Today is also very coincidentally the
last episode of the year which happens
so perfectly.
I was going to lie and say it was
episode 100 today just so we could hit
that milestone,
but I didn't need the lie.
It was episode 100.
He actually was that.
I was in the car.
It's just going to skip 99 so we're
going to skip that and just be like,
I don't know.
You guys are talking about but magically
it's episode 100.
We have so much a look back on.
So today what we're going to do,
and I think is going to be a lot of fun,
is I'm going to bring in and Dan out,
we're going to all sit here and share
our favorite and our worst moments of
the first 100 episodes because think
back to our first episode was Pewdie Pie
sitting in his rental house in La and
you,
you look,
well we weren't live streaming for like
the first 10 or 15 episodes.
It was like eight.
And we had like a really weird desk here
that one and the guests would sit on
this purple couch.
It was very strange,
but the big breakthrough I think came
for us when we started live streaming
it.
And when we got this table Ed,
we started to feel the format more.
And obviously I'm still developing a
lot.
Um,
God,
please,
please God let there be room to grow.
We haven't.
You always said that the rule is the
first hundred or you don't know what
you're doing until the first hundred
episodes.
That's what,
that's what I say.
And,
and kind of a master now,
please God,
let that be true.
No,
there's,
there's been so much to learn.
Someone said that you don't know until
the 2:50
episodes.
Yeah,
we gotta we gotta push that back because
now that we're at $100,
the pressure's on.
I heard Joe Rogan say you don't know
until a thousand,
so I think we still have a lot of room
to go.
Um,
so we're going to bring everyone out.
We've got a ton of great things to look
back on it.
I mean,
we've been doing this for two years.
It took us two years to get to 100
episodes.
There's a lot of great moments that I
forgot even happened that we're going to
look over.
Um,
so I can't wait.
I'm super excited and just everyone
who's tuned in and stuck around for this
wild.
I thank you so much.
It's been an incredible journey here and
I'm looking forward to getting to that.
But before we do,
we had our huge charity stream on
Tuesday,
which we streamed for eight and a half
hours the longest day of my life.
Still recovering from that.
That was absolutely brutal.
And against all odds we hit $100,000
live.
Hell yeah.
Couldn't believe it.
I had to live because I was sick.
I'm still kind of sick.
But um,
I got home and I think you just raised
to 75 and I him,
that's it.
You guys were going to leave.
But Justin was like,
no way.
I'm not 100.
And then it happened pretty fast.
Like I couldn't believe it.
Um,
why is it not letting me sign into my,
you need permission from Ethan?
I'm,
I am Ethan sign into while letting me
log into this stats at any word with
this email and I'll get you.
So at any rate we uh,
well yeah,
because I could tell first of all,
Zach,
our sound guy had a finals the next day.
Everyone was,
they got here before us.
I was like,
they were,
they were here for like 15 hours that
day.
And so everyone was getting tired and I
was like,
all right,
we can't,
you know.
But,
but justin pushed us on and it was so
good that he did.
Yeah,
we hit it.
Okay,
here we go.
I got access,
so let's say I want to go over some
stats.
I'm,
I'm very,
I'm always fascinated by what reward
item raised the most money because it's
always unexpected and by the way,
this is still up for another 10 days so
you can still bid,
you can still donate and help out a
great cause like in the description in
the description.
So top donors,
I got say we inched out Alex for 100
bucks because they,
you ula donating from home,
you donated 400 from home and we got
there now there are so many super
generous people here.
I'm going to out Justin.
That was justin.
That was very generous of him.
Alex was very generous.
James Wayne Hoff donated a 2000.
100 will cheer up.
Donated 2000.
I mean so many more.
Sookay the channel.
Yeah,
we had him.
He was chilling on the background.
Yeah.
And then we're going to take a call
who's calling in later today?
A fifths.
Just a few more down on that list.
God bless him.
So button at a time on Tuesday,
but we'll,
we'll speak to him later in the episode.
Here's the real interesting stuff.
So of all the rewards here is what
raised the most money and again you can
bid on all this stuff.
Okay.
Get the heck out of here.
This pivot table.
So most of all was nothing.
These generous and efforts,
everything like I was $26,000
from the kindness of my heart.
Yeah.
Pretty amazing.
And then Alex crushed what that limited
edition a.
The Journal,
the Journal raise $12,000.
So this,
I love the Nintendo switch coming in a
$300 investment.
We bought one of every gaming system,
a switch,
a ps four,
an xbox and together combined.
And that was a last minute idea over
years,
right?
Uh,
yeah that was good one.
So that 1200 bucks raised $20,000.
That was the best fricking return.
Authentic whenever.
But the switch raise 9,000.
That's so cool.
Post Guitar,
I'm happy to see raised $8,300,
right?
Something on Ethan's food book.
God bless rick and morty script lots of
original art hugging it out.
Oh,
I think I put a thousand on that one.
God,
I hope I get it.
People are gonna.
Think it's a rigged.
If I get it though,
what do we do about that?
It's random,
but then there's so many,
but the really guys,
I want to encourage everybody to keep
donating because if you go down to the
bottom,
a lot of the original art that we drew
towards the end,
they didn't get that many donations.
Original Alex Hirsch artwork by Justin
Rayland.
Eight bucks.
If you go put eight bucks on that right
now,
you have a 50 percent chance.
I'm going to go put eight bucks on that.
There's a ton of shit.
What are the original Justin reuland
artwork by Alex search?
A 100 bucks signed rick and Morty
skateboard.
That's all of our signatures.
100 bucks.
Original Alex Hirsch artwork pop mash up
The shredder one.
Where was that one?
That one.
Shredding nation original.
Alex Hirsch,
artwork shredder.
Nash vape nation.
Only two 60.
There was one of my drawings there.
Whereas,
I mean,
they're all still 300.
No under.
Yeah,
there's another one lower.
Oh,
their original isla artwork featuring
Justin Alex.
180.
So this shit is valuable.
I think really valuable.
There's original art by three frigging
amazing artist.
So if you want to help support the
cause,
please consider donating and you have
the chance to win some beautiful,
wonderful original art in so many other
great prizes.
I encourage you to go check that out.
Stem.
The prizes were crazy.
The prizes were bananas frankly.
And also the rick and morty comic
original comics signed.
Where's that one?
[inaudible] that.
Oh,
here it is raised 4,000.
I think that thing's worth honestly,
50 value.
So you already have a good chance of
winning that I think a good value for
your money.
So there you have it.
There's a lot of amazing prizes and I
think everyone that was a.
That was an amazing ride.
One it.
What are we at now,
Dan?
Like 130,000
or something?
Yeah,
I think we've just broke that uh,
right before going live.
Cool.
Continues to climb.
Good.
And also it's such a tough time for
people with the Christmas holiday
gifting and so people are really
generous and that sounds very generous
and I want to say because I'm afraid I
didn't emphasize it enough during
because it was focused on getting the
call,
I was like,
please let me go home.
No,
every dollar matters.
And to everyone,
everyone who even dropped $1 to help is
just,
it makes a big difference.
It's super generous and it's very much
appreciate it.
It's a beautiful thing and it's tax
deductible.
I don't know how much a $1 tax deduction
will get you,
but you know,
hey,
mark it off.
Like you said,
every bit counts.
You know,
Benjamin Button said a penny.
A dollar deducted is a dollar earned a
button.
Yeah,
Benjamin Franklin,
I believe it was the one that did a
little remix.
Alright,
well enough of that shit.
Let's get on to our favorite moments of
2018.
So I would like to welcome,
I'm the other half of the show with whom
it would not be possible and who I want
to say Dan and Ian come in here.
I'd like to say have truly been a
blessing to the show.
I want to say that their presence has
made such a difference and add is so
much presence.
Ian Bring so much character to the show
with his powerpoint.
Do we have a powerpoint today?
Fire?
No.
Ian and Dan,
please join us.
We couldn't do.
We couldn't do a year end recap without
these two guys.
Um,
so what's going on?
But yeah,
what happened when that Kanya decoding?
We were so slammed this week and with
the teddy fresh stuff too,
it was like I didn't have enough time
and has been doing all of our customer
support emails.
By the way,
if you ever complained,
you're talking to not talking to a
robot.
Nope.
That's it.
That's literally a slab.
That celebrity is answering your
question.
Yep.
So if you hit me with a,
you know,
fuck you.
That's right here.
It feels waco.
You got the first fuck you on supply.
You did.
I'll tell me about that.
Go on.
I didn't hear about.
Oh yeah,
you were out here and tell me
everything.
Well,
yeah,
I mean people go,
you know,
it's holidays,
heated,
very time sensitive.
How did you take it?
Did you take a person who could
instruct?
Well,
I exploded on him.
Flipped out.
No.
Listen Buddy,
you know,
it happened.
Well,
there's been a lot of delays and uh,
unfortunately there's a lot of packages
getting delayed.
Well just remember it's Ian's fault so
you this female,
but the truth is we're trying to get you
out of the trenches there because you're
a creative,
you're brilliant guy and I need that.
A big beautiful brain Ahmedi brain of
yours working in my benefit by decoding
stuff.
I need to,
I need to squeeze that valuable Jews
that it is worth.
And Dan has been with us longer than
anyone.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
Um,
it's crazy how times past,
but here we are.
Um,
and we'll,
let's talk about our favorite moments
now.
How should we do this?
I've got a bunch of mine.
Maybe I'll go.
Do you think they should present first?
Because I have a shit ton.
You guys have less than me now.
Well you have like the general stuff
stuff that came from fans.
Yeah,
I've got,
I've got it all.
Let's do those first.
So this is everything from the first 100
episodes now.
Joey Salads from the last charity
stream.
This will always go down as one of my
favorite moments and as history.
Now the backstory of this is that,
um,
because at the time we weren't really
equipped to live stream,
so joey salads live streamed it from his
phone on his personal twitch gentle that
went across the street from the office
and we,
yeah,
we watched it with a delay but we had
them on the phone so we were hearing the
audio through the phone and then
watching his stream which made it better
because we heard the screaming about 15,
20 seconds before the impact.
And I love how just so casually and
calmly,
Justin has accepted the bird pepper
spraying jelly south.
He loves it.
He had no hesitation,
just seemed there.
This was the legendary moment.
And um,
and funnily Joey Salads was banned from
twitter for doing a dangerous act.
But,
but art fine.
Oh,
poor guy.
I think he was three a reinstated.
Sorry,
joy.
Without further ado,
who was recording?
What was it like being there?
Seeing that this was like,
I've only been here a couple of weeks at
the time and I remember I called my mom
after I was like a guy just got pepper
spray work.
You afraid that it will reach,
you know,
you didn't feel it.
I kept the distance.
And so to this day Joe says that was
infinitely worse than a spicy pepper
trying to help you guys.
Kept it real professional.
Ian's following the action camera work.
It's Kinda like when you're filming like
a wildlife shot and like a,
like a gator is attacking a deer and you
can intervene and save the day.
No,
just watch the pain nature play on
Star Trek.
The rules of a non intervention.
It's the first protocol,
the first prime directive.
There you go.
Ian had a prime directive and you wonder
how could we top it next year,
but we're going to have to throw them
off a building.
We kinda,
yeah,
that's sort of an issue because um,
we,
we went for broke on that first one and
then because joey got a got banned as a
result,
were a little reluctant to go that far
again?
Well,
I didn't know what happened,
but I wanted to shoot him with a
nonlethal been back,
but I was like,
that's not,
that's not gonna fly.
So we have to.
The thing about the spicy peppers that
even though it's very painful,
it's not necessarily dangerous.
So Youtube doesn't see it as like a
bantible fence.
So if we can get a professional stuntman
and like a safety crew,
we may be able to throw them off a
building.
Maybe next time we can get some
submissions because I get some ideas.
We have a year lot of people listening
and next up buggy.
Now buggy is such an incredible guests
because he always,
he doesn't hold back and he has a,
he had a story on his last visit about
dating a feeder.
Just such a pleasure.
Such a pleasure.
And so here we go.
She,
oh she like,
come in and I'm so sorry to say this,
this is great cookies and she's laid
them across your chest,
down her stomach to make an arrow to her
vagina.
And then she had filled her Vagina
Maraschino cherries for dessert.
Swear to God.
And my first thought is,
you are going to get a yeast infection.
What the fuck are you doing?
Like don't put food in your vagina.
How many of you stuffed in there?
Six or seven.
I was like,
you know what I was experiencing in my
life.
I was like,
this is awesome.
And then do what you gotta do it.
Yeah,
no,
this was news to me out.
Yes,
quite,
quite literally.
And,
and,
uh,
and then we've been together for awhile
and then I got sick.
I got like an infection in my leg,
which is like real frequent.
I get in with the Olympic team all the
time and I'm like,
I gotta go to the hospital.
She was like,
they're going to make you lose weight.
And I'm like,
no,
that's going to be fine.
I go into the store to go to the
hospital and I'm like,
mom,
what are really.
Fuck you.
Okay.
We're done.
Like,
I'm not going to die.
She's faking the infection.
How do you fake an infection?
What do you pitch was twisted?
I mean,
well,
what's,
you know,
what ultimately is the goal of feeding
someone the,
that that leads to death.
That's the one path.
But uh,
what was it mentioned in this highlight
is that he did eat the cherries out of,
of her agenda.
What a guy.
What a legend.
Yeah,
I love that.
I like the,
on the highlight.
There was a comment from some guy
saying,
lady,
if you're watching this video,
I'm 300 pounds.
I put on weight.
I don't know if green Japan's qualifies
yet because Mcgee said he was at like
500.
That's right.
But I guess he's got lots of ways to go
have a for feeder.
There's a lot.
It's a long road to go together.
Um,
oh this.
Now this one I completely forgot.
This was submitted by a fan and this is
when we had ty Lopez on the cloud guys.
And we got him good because we had this
video where we went to his house and he
had a lawyer's,
a troop of lawyers following me the
whole time.
We decided to get him back when he came
on our own podcast and we hired an extra
that you found on craigslist,
right then?
Uh,
yeah.
Well I didn't actually.
Craigslist,
we all forgot that we did that one.
We saw the submission saying,
how'd you,
how'd you find them?
How to do,
what'd you mark put up?
Just need an actor for one day for like
an hour.
I got a lot of weird people so that was
a little but kind of comb through it.
And then he was very game.
We like put them in the closet because
you never know what you're going to get
with craigslist.
Especially actors are already all weird
and craigslist senators bottom.
But you,
you hit the Jackpot with that guy
because he was,
the guy was,
he played it completely straight.
It was amazing.
He sat in our tiny little closet room
for like an hour at least just because
we're like,
just being there,
need to use the bathroom,
go do it quick because you can't come
back.
He was so game to totally cool,
but what did we pay them?
Do you remember?
I don't.
I don't remember.
Probably probably more than girls get
for kissing.
Prank almost started a couple of
hundred.
I mean it was an easy day for him.
A couple hours after he had a couple of
hours.
I remember afterwards then he was like,
I know that guy.
He recognized,
ah,
I've seen his ass all over youtube.
Yeah,
exactly.
So here it is.
This is.
I watched this this morning.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is brilliant.
And he plays.
It is so straight to like you say,
wow,
that's noticeably flushed and walked
down there.
I love that shot.
How do we set the camera up?
Look at Thai.
I took,
I took a picture out the window one hour
or two hours before.
Right event that festival.
Completely ignoring what was happening.
Yeah.
Crazy world wants to look at the world
and he keeps imposing on him.
You,
uh,
you recently I was speaking at a
conference well to
entrepreneurs',
wanting to scale their business for me.
Just can you just bring a little bit
closer?
I just want you to miss anything.
Did you bring your lawyer?
Don't worry about he's not.
He's like an intern that's going to read
me my miranda rights.
Don't just try not to think about it.
No,
I'm just kidding.
He's got that.
He's got that lawyer getting the eyes.
Oh my God.
He's scaring me.
You're starting to scare me now.
So thanks for your service to us.
Very well done.
By the way.
Lots of intimidation there is going to
serve me.
And now another favorite V set.
Our first bank ever.
Like kind of a frank.
Really early episode.
I want to say ty was like 16.
17 was pretty early.
Yeah.
Really it was.
It doesn't feel that long ago.
Now that I see it,
but Tai Lopez was a year ago.
Let's see this one or a number.
Thirty three little higher.
Um,
October fourth.
So it was over a year,
over a year.
What is this cold open?
The new episode of the Eighth Street.
What does this look at?
This shit.
Whenever we ever started the podcast
starring your boy.
I remember when he had attorneys to
explained that.
Yeah,
that's cute.
Wasn't this live?
Might've prerecorded.
It was prerecorded.
Yeah.
The SOS.
Michael here.
One of my all time favorite guests.
Another guy is an open book.
He's hilarious.
We talked to him about taking Iowasca,
which is a psychedelic drug.
Yes it is.
And I thought it was a wonderful
conversation by the way.
I just realized that Dan is here.
It tells us about break time.
Oh,
it was telling us about.
is it break?
I've been keeping an eye on the clock to
3:45
will be 30 minutes late.
Vsauce is coming back our first episode
back 25th of January.
We'll,
we'll be joined by vsauce again.
So I'm very much looking forward to
that.
But here he talks about taking a
psychedelic drug,
um,
which is just the combination of him,
psychedelics and youtube red is just.
I love that.
Those three things together is not
something you would expect that he had a
lot of interesting things to say.
Here's the thing.
My heart was going.
It was literally beating very fast.
I actually,
there's a moment where I touch my chest.
I'm like,
Yep,
that's really happening.
But then I thought,
how do I let the doctor know?
Because
I can't think,
no,
this is not how I normally feel.
Is it weird if I just say,
Hey,
I'm help,
how are they going to interpret that?
And so I just,
I thought maybe I'll just ask for water,
you know,
maybe that like will tether me back down
to reality because someone will have to
bring me water.
And that's a really.
I've been there.
I feel like I've been in that headspace
of training.
They're like,
I don't want to see me talk.
But um,
that was great.
Love vsauce talking about that too,
because he was so analytical about his
experience,
which you know it most people who do
that are looking for some sort of
spiritual connection and he was more
just trying to like appreciate what was
happening to him the entire time.
It was really cool to hear him talk
about it.
Yeah,
I would,
I would like to just put Michael in a
room and just give them all kinds of
drugs and just,
Oh yeah,
record him.
Let's get that set up for the 25th.
I mean the new micro.
Here's a Mtma will leave,
you know,
tell us how you feel the new season is
out.
I'm very much looking forward to.
Oh,
nice.
Now we're going to talk all about that
on the 25th now.
Now garth brooks is somewhat of a
phenomenon here and on other podcasts as
well because he's just such a legend and
there's one video specifically of
Garth's that I love where he goes.
He's sitting in his hotel room.
Why don't I,
why don't we just watch it was,
I honestly can't.
I can't watch this too many times.
Garth Brooks face,
right?
Um,
I can't watch this video too many times.
It's truly a masterpiece.
Well,
I guess it's official.
We're now on facebook.
I really wasn't sure about this to
start,
but then a friend of mine said something
they just made also.
She said think of it more as a
conversation,
but I'm already finding out on my own.
So it's wiping the walls out between you
and me.
And I really liked that.
It allows us into each other's world.
Good.
The,
uh,
title Garth Brooks,
first facebook post and video.
Amazing.
Authentic and transparent.
One hundred percent.
That's funny because when I watched
this,
I see like the opposite
my case.
Oh,
tell me about.
This.
Reminds me of title
in,
in my garage video in that it tries to
look authentic and natural,
but you know,
he's done it a thousand dollars.
Take 40,
you'd lose for sure.
Looks like the type of video you'd make
from the bunker after the bombs have
fallen.
I really like that.
You know,
it'd be fun is to just maybe do like a
go fund me and then run this as a
youtube provable.
Go find me for people to donate and then
you use all that money as a,
as a community and you use this as a
youtube pre roll so people just get this
video.
Oh a go fund me to pay to have this as
an APP.
So it's just constantly popping up.
That's kind of.
That's good.
I mean it's,
he's not selling anything but I wonder
if you get pissed or if you'd loved
that.
I really liked that.
Be like,
what the fuck?
I mean,
that'd be great.
Let's try it to go fund me.
Think about things I want to post to
post cool stuff,
slick stuff,
neat stuff,
but most of the stuff I'm going to post
it gonna be raw stuff like this.
That's just who I am.
Truly a conversation tonight.
Nice.
They let the conversation begin
and iconically after saying,
let the conversation begin and was the
last video he ever poked?
Say let the compensation and incredible
stuff.
I'd never seen that until you showed it
to me and know I find myself doing that
like that.
I liked helping people think you're
being strange because they don't.
Oh,
I've done the without a doubt.
That happens to me a lot.
We used to watch it so many times,
but we didn't know what to do with it.
Like,
yeah,
I know but.
But it's wallet.
It was somewhat underground,
but I think a lot of people are picking
up on it now.
But the great moment,
one of my favorite moments was we had
Chris Delea on and I saw that he was a
garth brooks fan and the similar sense
that I was right and I says to him,
I pitched him this idea,
you,
I go,
you know what I want to do,
I want to recreate this video word for
word and just post it.
And he's like,
I think I've done that.
Right?
So here.
And we discovered that he did it and he
didn't even remember or recreate it.
I want to upload this to my youtube
channel on edited.
I think.
I think I did this.
You did.
You recreated it.
I know,
I know.
I sent the video to grow your role.
I know I sent it to Joe,
Bryan County.
I don't know if I ever uploaded it.
700 views.
It was some random person,
but somehow it's just five months.
Not even that long ago.
Oh yeah.
So somebody found him first.
I really wasn't sure about this start.
Oh,
so a friend of mine and I will say this,
I,
I didn't write it down.
I watched it.
Hi,
this is from A.
I remember I remember it.
Substrate feeling and authenticity.
Yeah.
I really liked that.
Has 50,000
different spray while saying that this
exists brought up.
You thought you bring it up.
I'm like,
Bro.
well,
you're in a hotel room.
Right?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Come on,
I'm immersed.
I guess it's official.
Ron facebook really wasn't sure about
this,
but did.
A friend of mine said something that
made all kinds of sense.
She said,
just think of it as a conversation.
I like that one.
I'm already noticing myself is that it's
wiping away the walls of communication
between you and me.
Well,
I really liked that line.
Is an invitation to fuck.
Fuck,
fuck.
I think facebook wise.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Everybody can see this each other's
worlds,
or in my case,
my hotel room,
one of the cool stuff,
slick stuff,
neat stuff,
but I'm probably gonna end up posting
stuff like this because it's who I am.
Well,
I guess if this is a conversation,
then I say lit.
The conversation began.
I
stumbled upon that,
like accidentally go and as he said,
it's now from 700 to 50,000.
Don't anyone ever say that we here at
the podcast didn't make a difference
bringing joy to the world on some guys
channel it is break time now.
Oh,
it is break time.
So we have a lot more next week about
posts.
Milan,
Patrice Wilson,
live spook.
That was not a job.
We've got so much,
so much more and then my worst moments
coming up and then your guys as best and
worst moments coming up and putting it.
You do not go away guys.
This is episode 100.
Yes.
Getting started and I say let the
conversation again and we'll be right
back.
These days you can get practically
everything on demand,
but why can't you get stamps?
Did you know that?
You can get postage on demand.
All you need is stamps.com
with stamps.com.
You can access all the services of the
post office right from your desk.
You can buy and print real us postage of
any letter or any package all available
24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
You just click print,
mail and boom,
Bada Bing.
Bob's your uncle.
You're done stamps.com.
We'll even send you a digital scale so
that you can weigh it and then properly
print out the postage for it.
You literally do not have to go wait in
lines at the post office anymore.
With stamps.com,
you're fully equipped.
You've got the scale,
you've got the means.
Do it from home.
For Christ's sake.
We do everything else from home.
Why not ship?
Now we've got,
we just did this charity a live stream.
We've got a ton of stuff to ship guests.
How we're doing it.
Baby stamps cost,
right?
Because there's no easier way.
That's the.
That's the situation right now.
We've even got a special offer for h
three listeners for week free trial
includes postage and a digital scale,
so don't wait.
Go to stamps.com,
and before you do anything else,
click on the radio
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinhthreeforthatspecialofferthatstamps.com.
Go to the microphone and enter h three
are you crunching for Christmas?
Trying to find that perfect gift while
no worries,
because everything you need for you and
your loved ones is over at me undies and
that's right,
mandy juices,
the coveted micro modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton
and you've never felt fabric this soft,
so get ready to experience the pure
bliss and underwear for him.
Now,
a lot of us walk around wearing normal
cotton underwear and you don't
understand how important it is for this
beautifully soft and micro modal to rub
up against your precious jewels.
It will change your life.
You will do not understand how soft and
luxurious this is.
Look at Isla.
They're showing these beautiful,
luscious,
red undies off.
You can also get stabbed of perfectly
suited for you or your specialist,
someone.
Men.
Women can choose from four different
cuts,
all of which are available from classic
colors too.
Adventurous prints.
I'm talking jack-o-lanterns,
holiday plaid,
and of course my personal favorite milk
and cereal.
Seriously,
these fun on these would be a great
stocking stuffer,
but why stop at Aldi's?
Mandy's has cozy lanch bands in once.
He's in that super same soft fabric.
Perfect.
We're wearing on Christmas morning.
Mandy's has got a great offer for my
listeners.
For any first time purchase.
When you purchase any Mian,
he get 15 percent off and free shipping.
That's right.
Crunched for time.
You can't go wrong with me and his gift
card,
so it's a no brainer.
You get 15 percent off the most
comfortable underwear they will ever rub
up against your genitals.
You make cream your pants,
but only the first couple of times,
so you'll get used to it.
It's that comfortable to get 50 percent
off your first pair,
free shipping and 100 percent
satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible].
That's [inaudible] dot com slash h
three.
Now through December 25th,
23 and me DNA kits are on sale,
23 me helps you understand what your dna
can tell you about you and your family
story.
It's named for the 23 pairs of
chromosomes that make up our DNA.
Now when you take this,
you get 90 plus personalized genetic
reports that offered DNA insights to
what makes you unique and it's so easy
to do.
All you do is spit in a tube provided by
23 and me kit,
which is the sexiest thing I've done all
year.
Register your sample to your personal 23
me account and in a few weeks Bob's your
uncle.
You receive your personal lives online
report.
Here's some things that it can tell you
about yourself just from analyzing a
little spit mosquito bites.
How prone are you to get bitten by
mosquitoes?
Do you like the taste of some lunch and
some people say so much.
It tastes like a dishwasher soap.
I thought they were insane,
but it turns out it's all genetic
musical pitch.
Can you tell musical pitch?
Can you recognize?
Huh?
That's interesting.
Wellness muscle composition.
Do you have the muscles of a power elite
power athletes?
Damn,
I did have that,
a genetic variant,
and so please address me as sir in the
future and sleep.
Move your arms and legs twitch while
you're sleeping.
While they've got to sleep.
Movement report.
You can discover how your genetics may
influence how much your arms and legs
move during sleep and so,
so,
so much more.
It's a fascinating look into your
genetic makeup.
It's so unique and so interesting.
It's so fun.
Now through December 25th,
you get 30 percent off any 23 and me
kit,
order your DNA kit at 23andme.com/eight
three.
That's the number two,
three and me.com/
[inaudible] three.
Again,
that's 23 and me.com/hp
to get 30 percent off through December
25th.
Give it a shot.
I love that.
Dollar Shave Club has everything I need
to look,
feel and smell.
My very best,
but love even more is the fact that I
never have to go to the store.
That's because $1 shave club through
everything I need right to my door and
two,
they keep me fully stocked and what I
use,
so I never run out.
Here's how it works.
By Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for
it.
They have you covered head to toe for
your hair,
your skin,
your face,
even your butthole,
you name it,
they've got it,
and they've got this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on the products,
you use,
your term,
you determine what you want and when you
want it,
and it shows up right to your door from
once a month to every six months.
That's what I do.
I keep them coming every month and I
never run out.
Especially those one wipe Charlie's.
Let me tell you as far as but wipe
scope.
It leaves a nice tingle on my anus.
I'm telling you,
there's a tingle and I love about it,
but the shampoo was delicious.
It smells great.
Isla.
She's all over me,
but I think it's because of my clean
butthole.
I could be wrong though.
Um,
plus what is that?
Right?
This is the clean butthole,
but plus what they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
And right now they got a bunch of
starter sets that you can try for just
$5,
like their shower starter set,
which includes the shampoo after that,
the restock box ships regular sized
products at regular price.
So what the F are you waiting for?
Get your starter kits for just $5.
Give them a shot.
See if you like it.
See if it's right for you.
I have a feeling you're gonna.
Love these products.
So head on over to dollar shave
club.com/h
three.
Give them a shot.
Try it for just five bucks.
That's dollar shave club.com/h
three.
Hey,
we're back.
Thanks for sticking around everybody.
We are here to celebrate the 100th
episode of the podcast and look fondly
back hard.
Um,
where was I posted?
Malone?
Never heard of.
Always a favorite.
Always a treasure to have them on.
But during,
was it his last appearance?
I think so.
Um,
there was the live show after that.
So yes,
um,
during one of his appearances here,
Patrice Wilson started live streaming
some really creepy stuff that seemed to
be directed towards me and we were
watching this unfold live and it was
very spooky.
So he,
so he started broadcasting just a shower
curtain.
Three x three was in the title.
Exactly.
And so we'll look for yourself.
Yeah.
Oh God,
I'm scared.
What is that creepy fucking screens,
dude?
I have chosen.
I didn't know there was so creepy.
It's like a CD screen,
like a screen with a gun in it.
He was just moving behind it.
No,
this is not a screen that scared the
shit out.
Turn this off.
So we were all getting,
we were all getting the.
Yeah.
Uh,
Patrice Wilson is already a guy that's
just a little strange.
That's fair.
I think in the fairway,
but I just thought it really scared the
shit out of me when I saw this and it.
And it continues.
So,
so this happened early on in the episode
and we closed it.
We're like,
all right,
we can't have.
This is way too scary.
And later on the live chat was saying
he's back and it's changed and this part
really scared the shit out of me.
Here you have it.
He's got a countdown timer,
a graveyard posts in a cemetery.
Griffey I love you.
Goodbye.
I'll spend the night with you.
Well,
I'm worried about December first.
That's what I'm saying.
On December first,
let's do a getaway.
I don't want to be in la because he's
here.
Fuck that.
Let's just hold up with some shot.
He's fucking.
I've room in your house.
There's not.
It's a very vulnerable and it makes me
very vulnerable.
And you can attack from anyone here who
knows the way worse now I've got a
defensible high ground
when the time clock and ended,
we left the house.
We didn't want to be in the house just
in case I want you hiding in a grocery
store park.
So when the time when we got down to
zero,
it was getting more provocative and more
threatening.
I felt.
And I felt so unsafe in our last house
as well that I was like.
And we just had got.
Do we have shutter at the time?
I was really scared for shredder and so
we,
we packed up,
we got shredder,
we went in the car and we just drove
into a public parking lot and just held
up for a couple of hours because I was
like,
look,
I don't fucking know you guys up to at
all.
No,
I would have done at least that town for
the day.
But then patrice was like,
why did everyone think this was creepy?
Rolling through a cemetery.
There was even more heat directly
addressed to you at some point.
Yeah.
He was like,
I'm coming for you.
And like,
yeah,
no,
I know.
Um,
that was a wild one,
but it was special.
We shared it with post live and it was a
beautiful moment.
It's just one of many,
uh,
Jordan Peterson hits the vape God.
Now there's an internal debate and this
office,
because we have retired,
the vape God.
And I think for guests like Jordan
Peterson is so fantastic to have them
hit it,
but isla hosted opinion and she's not
necessarily wrong that it's really
disgusting and weird requests,
but you know,
and I,
I appreciate that.
She thinks it's dirty,
but we keep it clean,
don't we?
Oh sure.
What you cleaned.
Yeah.
I and there's not much.
Yeah,
I mean we,
we wipe off the tube and sterilize it
before somebody new hits it or whatever.
But um,
to me it's more so that it's like right
off the bat,
some people might feel obligated to do
it when they really don't want to.
And then that starts the interview on a
weird foot.
Well,
but we're,
I mean as I guess we're about to see the
person I thought would be like,
hell no.
And uh,
he was super down.
That's the problem,
right?
Is that you on one hand,
say this was a little strange and
they're going to be uncomfortable,
but I know on the other hand you have
moments like this.
Okay.
So I'm happy to comply.
Rip It.
Okay.
Sorry,
I just breathe out,
but then I got the button that rips
nice.
He's fucking legendary.
Damn.
You know the cops are battery powered.
He's Canadian.
Let's listen.
Let's be honest.
I mean they know.
They know how to do this up there.
I'm impressive.
I remember he said a rituals are
important.
That's fine.
Was He the first one?
We may do that.
No,
we had hardly and Bobby Lee and
everybody did it.
We had a lot of people doing it.
I feel like he was the first time I was.
He was thinking that too because it.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
It tastes like battery acid or some
days.
Gotcha.
Sleeping that it goes through a
definitely.
It makes it taste a little funky,
but it's all good.
He was unfazed back then.
It were older,
there was still
a clean hit,
but as time has gone on,
it hits so harsh that you feel like
battery is the thing.
It was,
it was made as a prop and so you know,
it's not necessarily over the longterm.
So.
So what you're saying,
Dan,
is that we need to build a more,
a more resilient little regarding not a
prop center,
if you,
if you own a vape company out there,
hit us up podcasts@hvhcproductions.com.
Well that was a special moment
regardless of if it was right or wrong.
Justin Pranks,
Joel Osteen,
another great moment from last year's
charity event,
we called it Joel Osteen is this mega
preacher who was in the media at the
time because he closed,
they had this horrible hurricane,
hurricane and tons of people were
homeless and without shelter.
And Joel,
a man of God had this mega church and
the worst area on the high ground,
completely unaffected by the flooding
and the church was closed.
He wasn't letting anybody in there.
So he was getting slammed all throughout
the media and we took it upon ourselves
to vigilante justice.
And Justin calls in Joel Osteen and the
woman who answers is just,
I mean,
lack of a better term,
a little bit of a loony tune.
I think that's more than fair.
Yeah.
So here we go.
Keep saying ricky,
do you.
Do you know someone named,
started talking to Ricky?
Todd.
Todd,
todd,
todd.
Todd.
What is.
What does any of this mean?
I'm confused.
If I were to translate this,
would it be.
Would it be like,
Hey,
don't let people into the building
during the flood because we don't want
the steps.
I heard you the first time I heard it
the first time.
What did Jesus?
Twenty 15,
2015 was a good year.
Flight News.
Flight News battles.
Is that a magazine or what are you
talking about?
I am so confused right now because it's
supposed to be some kind of.
Yes.
Oh,
it's apparel line per line where you
just ramble.
Crazy.
Nonsense.
What language is this?
I just,
I'm going to call my translator so I can
follow the conversation.
Keep pop,
pop,
Tuck,
tuck.
Ricky,
taxi.
Puppy.
Topic topic.
Ricky ticky.
Tacky Paki.
Pocket talky.
Talky.
Laughing at it because you know it's
funny because it's ridiculous.
That's why you're laughing right now.
I just
made the demon.
Satan.
This is a thing apparently.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's part of the ritual to a purge the
evil out of her phone calls.
Dude,
that was so crazy.
That was so much more insane than I ever
could have expected.
You have to.
Yes.
He seems kind of.
I may get some out of that.
Do we still have that number?
You want to call it a couple of Ricky
ticky tack?
Yeah.
We'll take shit too far.
This is what this is Christianity on.
This is what happens when you overdose
on Christianity at the blood of Jesus.
Oh my God.
Everything in moderation with folks to
keep talking to you.
Fuck you.
Fuck you're dying of Shit.
She's going to put me up to the next
level was prayer line.
She's like,
I'm putting.
I'm putting time speaking in tongues.
I cannot believe that was a special
moment.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean,
yeah,
find someone that's just start speaking
in tongues and laughing.
Okay.
Damon is a beautiful moment.
I remembered that made national news,
but like there were like article about
viral moment,
right?
Yeah.
Also,
the previous one made it into articles
with post malone because he was saying
he was talking about when the dream was
going to end December first he joked,
he joked and then people thought.
We said that was the day beer bongs and
belly and the drama and everything.
Refer.
Billboard was like thought that was the
data release,
just goofing around and then act on
December first.
I felt bad because he had to tweet out
Saturday.
Everybody album's not coming out today.
It was so obviously joking.
What the hell people.
Oh yeah,
that was great.
I mean huge like rolling stone billboard
poster,
loan reveals and when I saw those
articles I was like,
wait,
where did he say that?
And then to find that it was our
strategy.
Talking about poetry.
It's funny because they don't mention
this yet.
No,
they're just like post Malone said
bastards.
They had mentioned the show.
People would have been like,
oh,
it's not serious.
Right.
Jack.
Now,
this was a moment that I personally
loved is that the night before the Jack
Black episode aired,
Justin reuland reached out to me and he
said,
do you know that I used to,
I met Jack Black Lung,
the goal,
and he helped me pitch and sell my first
show ever.
And he's a huge inspiration to me and
was a huge help to me.
And he sent me all this incredible
media,
like pictures that said,
what did it say?
Keep,
um,
doors down,
knocked the doors down,
um,
and he had even done a cameo in his
first show that he sold.
And Jack talking about how
like,
um,
Bob Odenkirk,
Bob Odenkirk and David Cross had given
them their big break by putting them on
Mr Show.
And so that Kinda gave me the perfect
end to be like,
well,
somebody at you,
you've apparently,
uh,
you know,
passed it on.
This was a beautiful moment.
I understand that from a mutual friend
of ours.
You are also an advocate.
I have,
I have a surprise,
somewhat of a surprise in what God is.
Am I going to be surprised by someone
from blast from my past going to enter
the room?
I think so,
no.
I'm really excited.
A friend of mine,
I launched out.
God because he heard you were going to
be a show and I don't know that you've
seen this.
He said,
but I think that you want to say for the
record,
I think that's one of my favorite
episodes we've ever done.
Yeah,
I know it's recent,
but honestly like to have the best
guests we've ever had.
Just so cool.
So funny.
They hung out before and after they sang
for us after that.
It was incredible.
We probably never.
Was that like,
can we have a wii?
So Zach,
who's our sound lad,
he's a musician.
He shreds on guitar.
Well thank you very much.
And He um,
kyle gas is like a crazy shredder.
And so Zach and Kyle and Jack started
jamming and sinking.
Yeah.
Zach knew a master exploder,
which was a tenacious d song and uh,
I think it was asking Kyle about his
guitar.
It was like,
here,
take a look or whatever.
And he just started busting out into the
song and like I had like a split second
moment of like,
oh,
like,
you know,
don't try and show them up or whatever.
I was completely wrong.
They immediately just launched into the
song and they like play the entire song
with him,
sing the whole thing.
It was so cool.
How was that for you,
Zach?
Who was one of the highlights of my
life.
I do have a video of it on my phone,
but I said,
oh Sheila,
to get that up.
Maybe we can tweet it later.
Something to eat it later from the
podcast flutter.
That'd be great.
It was insane.
It was just like he started singing and
that was just like,
oh my God,
I can't believe this is happening right
now.
I could tell on Zach's been living out a
fantasy for us.
Yeah,
they really,
I mean those guys.
And Jack Black is such a legend.
Like man,
I used to be obsessed with his HBO
series is one of the funniest things
ever.
And originally it really when we were
researching for them coming in.
Um,
as part of that,
I went back and watched some of it had
been years.
I haven't seen it in forever.
Completely holds up so funny.
So it doesn't hold up.
Hold up.
I find this joke a fairly tasteless.
You remember the but babies in the
desert where Kyle gives handled birth.
Oh my God,
I love that.
So good.
But at any rate where we be joined by
it.
Wow.
You will be joined by.
It's never been Lloyd.
So hang on.
Here we go.
Tell me if you recognize this.
Oh my God.
It's just an reuland.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So speaking
of Virginia,
so Justin Reuland,
Jack Black helped Justin reuland pitch
and sell his first show as eap.
Wow.
Jack helped him get his foot in the
door.
No,
by the way,
Jack is amazing.
He helped me and he believed in me and I
just want to say hi and thank you.
And that he loves.
What a mench.
Well,
let me see because you did.
It can be able to convey that sincerity
to Jack Black come up as good as it
gets.
Definitely.
And the fact that Justin had the picture
still as good as it gathers polaroids.
I guess they are.
Let me,
let me find that for thing.
But he doesn't throw away and I know.
I know in Jack.
Actually,
I never conveyed what Justin said
because I showed them that clip and he
cracked up laughing when Jack was like,
oh,
Justin's a saver.
Because Justin is a hoarder.
When you go in his house,
you're going to tell this guy doesn't
throw anything out there it is.
There it is.
Modest.
But he.
This is what he told me.
Okay,
look,
I couldn't believe he sent me this photo
last night.
Blow doors down.
He's a saver,
but I can't believe how young men.
He's a different person.
He's a sweet kid.
Dude.
Look at him.
I was wild.
I know.
Look at that little genius.
Just a true genius.
Oh God.
He's like,
he's like one of these crazy geniuses
that are fearless and like on hesitant,
you know,
like he doesn't have a filter in the
best way possible.
And he's just,
he embraces these,
like his game coming out.
It's so imaginative and it's just,
it's like,
so uniquely him,
you know,
it's almost no one else could have made
it,
but him,
he really is such a creative force and a
truly an honor to consider him a friend
and this was just really one of my
favorite moments probably.
So there you have it.
Next,
what do we got?
Oh,
here's a great one.
I'm almost done with my list.
By the way.
Martin scarelli admits to doing crimes
alive.
I couldn't believe I forgot this.
This is legendary.
This was another one of those unplanned,
beautiful genius moments where we're
having a live show with,
I think it was eric and Jesse wellons
and somebody,
and this was right after scarelli got
like a sentence that are convicted.
He was convicted.
It was before the sentencing,
which is is key to why this was so
amazing because it was very much
underplaying how much punishment was
coming as well.
He didn't know and he,
he seemed pretty confident when he was
saying he seemed to have the feeling
that he was getting off with a slap on
the wrist and he,
he asks us,
well,
how much?
He's like,
I'm not admitting anything but how,
how much jail time would you do for
$100,000,000?
And we're like,
what do you mean by that?
How did it happen?
We were just talking about him and then
he and he was streaming and then I
started watching our stream on history
back.
I just keeping an eye on the chat and
people were just started spamming in the
chat.
Hey,
uh,
Martin Shkreli is like streaming right
now.
And he's watching you guys was like,
what the fuck?
Sure enough.
So we're like,
well we've got,
we've got to get squirelly on here if we
can.
And after you know,
trying to align it up,
we finally figured out and got them on
and and well here,
let me play the clip for you because
this truly.
He's in prison right now and I've always
suspected that this clip of him on our
show was played before the judge,
once before sensitive thinking.
He goes,
listen to this,
listen to this crazy question.
If you could make $100,000,000,
but you had to go to jail,
how much time would you do?
Is this related to your situation?
Totally.
Totally unrelated because you just spent
$30,000
and I flick your answer was sarcastic.
It seems to be a little bit of.
I mean for how much water mill?
Hundred million.
If I fucking Tony Sorento for $100,
million dollars,
how much time would you do?
He asked just money.
How much time would I do?
And My,
my,
you're the orange.
Is the new black.
Is it on the expense of people who
suffers straight up like,
hey,
serve a year.
Here's a bunch of money.
Nobody suffers.
What would you.
What would you do?
Zero to zero to 30.
Oh,
zero to 30 days.
Criminal especially sense.
So even if you assume I'm guilty of not
coming out of this with over 100 million
dollars and he locked the judge took all
pretty much all of his money.
Right?
Including honestly when,
why even go on at that point.
But he's a cocky bitch.
He couldn't help but brag.
Right?
And if he couldn't come help,
uh,
come on and be like,
if you could make $100,000,000,
how much time would you do it?
Kept it kept going on,
on this trans about how people just
don't understand that he's not scamming
anyone is just messing with the
insurance companies to help fund more
research.
And this dream.
I've,
I've learned a lot more about the topic
and it was totally.
That's the talking point of all these
pharmaceutical companies who jacked the
price up like a times.
They always say the same thing that he
was saying and I guess he convinced some
people that that's true,
but what they say is,
oh,
well,
by raising the price of 100 times,
we make it more accessible,
which is like a total,
like double speak,
counterintuitive,
but they say it gives us more money for
research and it helps us subsidize
people who can't afford it except that
there's actually no evidence of any of
these guys giving it out for free.
Like they supposedly say they do.
Well.
And also the people that pay for it as
health insurance and government and
social security so ends up costing
taxpayers like a billion dollars.
Yeah.
Or more,
probably a lot more.
But uh,
at any rate,
um,
and he also wasn't in that clip,
but I remember in that interview,
um,
he was like,
I'll get six months.
That was his destiny and it's seven
years,
more than six months.
And then they took money and they took
the Wu Tang album.
I mean,
there.
Yeah,
there you have it.
His story is one that's just so
fascinating that he became so notorious.
Like he,
he said it in this interview and he's
right,
there's way bigger offenders than he is
that are way more powerful and way more
wealthy and way more.
I would say,
well,
I don't know about way more,
but they are predatory on a larger
scale.
They will avoid scrutiny.
But somehow he was made notorious by the
media,
I guess because he's put himself out
there probably.
Yes.
Sacrifice the anonymity that the other
guys like cherish in exchange for being
like a meme,
a meme,
Lord in the public eye.
So you want it to be a cool,
edgy.
He paid the ultimate price.
It is an interesting thing though,
because I mean,
his big mistake in a way was just being
honest about what he was doing.
Like he just,
he was kind of weird.
How is that?
I mean,
uh,
you know,
trying to make that argument that it
wasn't fraud.
I mean,
obviously the court did not agree with
that.
Um,
but,
but just raising the money and
everything,
you know,
he,
what he said oftentimes was just,
you know,
all these companies do this.
Um,
I agree.
No,
that wasn't on their investigations.
Now,
maybe not all,
but a lot of them are.
Well,
he lost in the court of public opinion
and that's why everyone went after him,
but we have to be Hillary Clinton's DNA
to.
Oh,
that's great.
That's the reason he ended up going to
prison is because he was on probation
and then he made a tweet sarcastically
asking anyone to get a sample of Hillary
Clinton's DNA so we could clone her.
Said I have the sequences,
and so the judge determined that he was
hilarious,
but it wasn't worth it.
They joke like probation.
He was out on bail and bond and they
removed his bail is a judge that he was
a threat to public safety,
but actually he did.
He ended up going to prison for.
It had nothing to do with the medicine.
It was.
He defrauded investors,
have a,
a hedge fund.
Amazing stuff.
Well,
yeah.
It's like
you're involved in so many shady things.
You went to prison for the one that
always the good guy.
He's the good guy to him.
Always remember Squirelly for rip her
Rhombi.
Yeah.
Let's pull that up because that is
generally up.
I'd watch a scary movie that's probably
coming late.
What does that mean?
Wait,
you would watch?
Oh yeah.
I would watch.
Let's.
Let's do it.
This is literally straight later.
He's a fascinating guy and I'll tell you
what,
every time you he's streaming or
something,
he's always sitting alone home by
himself,
like he's like the loneliest dude ever.
It's pretty sad,
but here he is trolling CBS.
Now
further away you talk about being upset.
Harambie who is the gorilla that was
killed at the Cincinnati Zoo on twitter?
Talk about caring so much about them
that the life meant so much.
The Cincinnati Zoo was come out and
asked people to stop using means and
you've.
You've used it,
a lot of memes and social media.
How is this going to stop in order to
honor him?
So it was sort of moonlighting.
Scientists,
you know,
I,
I work a lot with nonhuman primates.
We call them in the labs NHP.
So any rhesus monkeys capuchins all the
way up to the higher orders.
While my brother and I especially have
this deep fondness for,
for animals that are so close to humans,
so remarkably close,
in fact,
there are Benobos that can even
communicate with you on a one to one
level and tell jokes and be sarcastic
and funny and even flirt with you.
It's unbelievable how humanlike these
creatures are.
An idea that we just shot this whole one
day is the argument that is,
to be honest,
it's painful to even talk about this,
but back to the issue which is that in
in this country,
I don't think we value nonhuman primate
life the way we should.
I think these animals actually should
have rights.
We it or not,
if they did Martin,
they wouldn't be able to be used in the
pharmaceutical industry,
which don't think,
I don't think they should be.
You know,
I do a lot of and I've,
I've,
I've overseen the death of thousands of
these animals.
Rats and many times the overseeing.
Absolutely.
Every single pharmaceutical executive
house,
a Pfizer probably kills a million
animals here.
It's completely true.
That's fair to them.
You know,
if that doesn't,
I can't tell.
I can't either,
no,
because actually I do agree with what
he's saying,
but that,
but it's such a troll.
It's hard to get a read on
when you talk about that.
It feels like it is very,
it was a moral decision.
It's,
it's how you feel morally and yet when
you talk about drug prices,
when we were talking earlier,
and,
and I know you're saying it should go to
the insurance company,
is it's,
it's up to the insurance companies.
But why not have that same moral
compassion for the way the system is
more moral,
compassionate?
You know,
I mean,
uh,
I think that,
there's a lot of them,
for instance,
7,000
rare diseases.
There's only five or six companies in
the world that care about those
diseases.
The pfizers,
the mercks,
the ASTRAZENECAS.
I care about the big sellers,
but there's dying kids,
friends of mine,
like the closer brother's three kids
with Pekin.
I invented the first drug ever for Pekin
and these three kids,
they are staring at their death
sentence.
They're teenagers.
And uh,
I'm fighting my butt off to,
to save them and need money to do that.
Investors don't care for these little
diseases and so forth,
so I think that a lot more compassion
than most people think.
That's why I'm in the drug business,
but at the same time a nonhuman,
I find it also happens to be the most
lucrative,
but at any rate,
rest in peace around.
We went down the hall a little bit too
far and finally my favorite top moment
is dis.
Doctor disrespect,
jumping through the roof and here we
have.
All right.
Let's see.
Yeah,
let's see here.
You have knocked as well.
Wait a minute.
Knocked his hair back.
Hold on a second.
Look at me.
I forgot I got all dressed up like that.
I need to do something in that
character.
Character is great.
Professor Prophecy.
We may have another clip of prophecy.
Oh,
we have one coming up.
This was a pretty special episodes.
I'm God,
we got to do something.
I like that get a lot,
but you know,
worth mentioning is that a lot of people
criticized us.
By the way,
I don't have any problem showing.
He's clearly shown himself out of
costume now as many of you have seen,
but a lot of people were angry because
in fact they weren't even saying,
well,
this is the highlight.
Yeah.
Um,
they were even saying that we purposely
such wishes.
I always resented that because first of
all,
what chocolate,
what happened?
Oh,
at the end of the episode we always go
to like a slate and go to the wide.
And so as soon as immediately as the is
done,
he takes off his wig and classes and you
see him at a character.
But we do that at the end of every
episode.
And I,
I,
I had no way to know that he was going
to take everything off immediately.
Our attention.
I just did that,
right?
Yeah.
It's not actually in the episode because
we cut it out.
It was only in the twitch.
On twitch.
Yeah.
Actually somebody submitted a stock sing
a hymn,
doxing him as their worst moment in the
email.
So I actually do have that clip because
somebody re uploaded it,
which made sense.
Then he is showing himself a bunch of
times even before,
by the way,
even before that I did,
but hey,
what can you say?
There's a piece.
There's always someone to complain,
but not intentional.
No,
of course not.
People always assume the worst.
I've found they did it on purpose.
Yeah,
it was a huge plant.
That's the only reason I went.
Okay,
we're over and I'll take off your wig.
Right?
So there you have it.
Now I've got two worst moments to share
with you guys just selected by you.
These are selected by me.
Okay.
Now,
first of all,
worst moment we go way,
way back to our first live episode.
I'm sure you guys have all seen this
Joji Mehmed on me.
So bad way.
This was framed up just that we were
doing.
We were.
We were like hours in.
I was so drunk at this time.
We were just chit chatting.
I think we were talking about how like
in the animal kingdom,
let's look at shredder.
He's,
he's a serial rapist.
Okay.
Our dog and Fred or goes to the dog
park.
No,
seriously.
He goes out there and he'll fuck
anything that moves.
He doesn't ask for consent.
It will try.
And my only point is that back in the
day,
human beings like neanderthals or
whatever,
earlier form,
even apes,
they're out there.
They're,
I don't know that they're,
they fuck they,
you know what I'm saying?
Just I'll say.
Okay.
Does that make sense?
It was just like,
not,
not thinking research,
just some stupid like conversation.
Right.
Which is always what people get upset
about,
which is a couple of people shooting the
shit.
All right.
Just a fucking idiot.
I didn't pretend to be anything more
than just a fucking idiot and in this
case a drunk idiot.
But that being said,
I don't think anyone was actually
offended by this,
but it was just funny how it played out.
So here I am talking about that or apps
or whatever.
Right.
Our Art Watch,
neanderthal eulogies were probably just
breaking like crazy.
So there's definitely a neanderthal in
us to like conquer men want to like grow
up.
So it's,
you know,
women are in a nature setting,
like to be conquered.
It came out and it was super weird and
Super Long Island.
Actually the most brilliant part about
it.
Yeah.
The most brilliant part about this is
that I'm sure he didn't know his face
was in.
It's just pure,
genuine,
pure,
genuine reaction.
It's pure silence,
man.
You got me good.
Look at that shot.
Oh stole.
I still see this posted all the time.
I don't think I'll ever live that.
You got my good.
And then there's.
I have an honorable mention.
This is a new.
This is a new moment and I can't tell if
it's the best or worst.
So here we are entering a new moment
into the lexicon.
I saw this on the subreddit.
Someone who follows my dad on twitter.
Now you know when somebody likes
something on twitter,
blows up on their feed.
So someone decided to follow my dad on
twitter and he posted this on the
subreddit and dad,
I love you,
but you got to know something.
Things just you can't do.
You're a public figure.
Now Dad.
Gary liked a.
you've got a few hours left on abby
snaps to see how sexy yesterday was.
It's a girl eating out another girl,
dad.
You don't have to like,
like,
like you don't have to like porn elite
if you're going to look at it,
you don't have to slam a like on a
cruise.
Yeah,
he,
my dad got Ted Cruz told him that you
discovered this or I showed it to him.
I said,
dad,
just so you know,
is he watching the stream right now?
Probably Dad.
Just so you have to like it.
It shows up on other people's feet.
Had to play it off.
Cool.
He was like,
he said something like,
freedom with a bunch of exclamation
marks,
a legend and a dad find.
Look at porn.
You don't have to like it,
but I can just imagine this poor guy who
followed him,
who decided to follow my gut.
Just scrolling this twitter feed.
Now Gary likes.
It's such an old people facebook thing.
It's so brutal.
I can't decide if that's the worst,
but there you have a gear.
So I will now pass it off to you.
Uh,
you want to switch seats with me or no
man,
it's.
So.
It's just two links.
So set aside,
oh well,
it's kind of a rough change from the
last one.
Um,
I guess one of my favorite moments,
I don't know if it's like favorite,
it's weird to describe it,
but having a total biscuit on the show
and um,
later that year he passed away.
So that was just a surreal,
I guess,
experienced have here and they talked
about cancer and yet having him on here,
I'm so thankful that we had the
opportunity to have him on the uh,
so on the show when we did.
Seriously.
So here's the little excerpt that,
uh,
from,
from him talking about living with stage
four cancer,
let's make sure at that time counts for
something.
A lot of it is also,
you assume at this age you've got,
wow,
I've got 50,
60 years with the family.
What if you didn't?
While we know you don't know how long
you've got,
so you know,
make me want to try and be a better dad
was not out about that.
I wanted to connect more with my stepson
and then I have and I've been doing
that.
I want to connect more with my wife,
make sure that we get a good to,
you know,
we get go to run out of it.
I intended to be around when I'm fucking
100 years old will be still bitching
about video games if I can be,
but sometimes that might be something
outside of my control it,
you know,
maybe fighting isn't enough.
Maybe that's just not enough to keep
going,
but if that's the case then you've got
to make sure that you spend the time
you've got in the best way you can.
And even then it's not like it changes
you overnight.
Like you still want to go read reddit
comments.
You still want to go that shit.
People on twitter,
like you can't change the habit of a
lifetime,
but there's something in the back of
your mind that they have something bad
to do.
You know,
maybe that,
that does change over time.
I think.
Well and some burly,
he did pass away I think like five or
six months or maybe even less.
It really shocked me.
I just,
I mean he seemed.
I mean,
I know he was in pain and he was on
chemo and you see,
he was very,
he was very optimistic guy.
He was a fighter.
Yeah.
That's the thing about this disease,
you,
it doesn't show like you don't use the
person looks the same.
Right.
So you just don't see the decline in
their status.
And it was the same with my dad up until
the last moment.
He looked healthy,
like it looked fine.
I didn't even lose his hair and nothing
will look the same.
Yeah.
So it's shocking when it happens,
but I,
uh,
thought it would be cool to remember him
did.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I had watched him all growing up.
I mean,
like he was the starcraft guy and I was,
I played a ton of starcraft growing up,
uh,
and so that was surreal to even have him
in there at all.
And then to hear him talking about his
disease like that and so openly and with
so much optimism.
It was,
that was,
that was a special one.
That was cool.
Yeah.
I cherish that.
I look at the picture of us on the wall
like somewhat regularly.
Yeah.
And so last year,
what I remember from that interview was
he kept saying like,
you know,
five of my days are bad and two of them
are good and that's enough for me to
comment.
[inaudible]
yeah.
He left a hole in the gaming community
too.
That hasn't really been filled.
I feel like it's such a unique voice.
Yeah,
that is definitely true.
Um,
well God bless him.
[inaudible] Hammond,
Carl Jackson,
which was data.
Oh my God,
that's so fucking heartbreaking.
All happened at the same year.
I don't think we've ever talked about
Carl did.
We have,
we may have mentioned it.
He was a fan who,
uh,
had a rare type of cancer that ate fat
cells in your body.
Super Rare.
So there's very little research about
how to cure it.
Right.
And he actually was a,
was a,
I would say,
a little chunky,
like originally before he had cancer,
kind of a larger guy.
And by the time I met him,
he,
I mean he looked like,
um,
like anorexic.
Wow.
And so he had awful rare form of cancer
that was just eating all this,
a fat cells away until he just perished
from,
just wasted away.
But he wrote us an email and we reached
out and we sent them gifts.
He was a huge fan of teddy fresh and
like he was a big fan of ours and I had
played pub g with him a couple of times
and we kept in regular contact and he
was such a sweet fucking dude.
He was such a sweet dude.
Is such a great outlook,
you know.
And I hadn't talked to him for.
Oh yeah.
And he went to like,
his only dream was to go to Disneyland
and he had this big a make a wish
foundation seminar to Disney.
And we sent them like 500 bucks or
something for spending money because
this fan,
he would have like a single mom.
There were,
it was like the saddest shit ever.
His Dad wasn't in the picture.
So just two weeks go by and I haven't
uh,
talked to him.
And then someone,
another youtuber who was in touch with
him just sent me like a dam or something
like,
Hey,
I just want to let you know in case you
didn't hear that Carl passed away.
I was like,
damn,
it's so tragic.
He was like 18 years old.
God,
are you looking for a picture?
I'm trying to send it here.
If you go through the email [inaudible]
ethan is twitter.
Oh,
there you go.
Oh yeah,
this is,
this is.
Yeah.
He was active on twitter and he was
really loving because people started
following them on twitter and he was
getting some really positive support and
attention.
I mean,
you can see how [inaudible] health then
he had become.
And um,
one day he just stops or a fat cells
that I've never heard of that.
I mean,
I guess you said it's super rare.
Super Rare.
That's crazy.
Uh Huh.
And one day he just,
his twitter stopped.
And when was that?
That was,
that I see is mom tweeted something.
I didn't see that.
I think this was the last thing I've
ever seen was him being like,
I totally didn't preorder this because
they have been super hand play.
Yeah.
He was a sweet kid,
man.
He was a fucking real sweet dude.
Not a part of the podcast,
but something that definitely we
experienced.
Sure.
But either you do have.
Oh,
you just have the worst snow.
So what's your worst?
How do you thought that very optimistic
person today though?
Maybe I.
Okay.
So the worst one was actually when I
went to Israel.
All right.
This actually works out because your
worst is actually pretty fun.
Um,
I went to Israel twice when my dad
wasn't feeling well,
but the first time a stayed and Kinda
fucked it up on the podcast.
So getting drunk and talking shit guys
that it shouldn't have.
And um,
so then I rescheduled that.
I will call in from Israel.
So that's the moment.
Hello.
Well it's up to you.
Didn't,
you don't know anything about this,
right?
You didn't,
you're not updated on all this.
Then I left for one day for one day.
Everything is ruined.
Lives is not my fault.
It's your fault.
You know what's going to happen.
You think that I can handle myself
without a carer.
You leave me in here.
I can't.
I can't deal with this.
You leave me in a room with Eric and
jacket.
Two bottles of Hennessy idea.
Was that how many pizza slices did you
have?
A lot,
dude.
That's all I was upset about it.
You just lose that weight even though
I'm sorry for smoking by the way.
I'm not smoking anymore.
I'm done.
That's the last cigarette.
You'll see me smoke on this podcast or
on the street.
Not entirely true,
but I think I've had like three
cigarettes since then.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's very good.
So
anyway,
did you.
Were you listening
there?
Yeah,
it was great.
That was actually a great way to break
the.
Well,
there you have it.
Isla is best and worst.
I'm very nice.
Now up next we've got Dan and Ian here
with the.
Let me see here.
We've got the.
Whereas this estrone worse.
Dan,
why don't we change spots?
That'll be.
That'll be better than has a few.
Let me go down to your spot.
So we all have best sim worse now,
Dan,
here you go.
There might've been some overlap but I
don't think so.
I don't think there is.
Alright.
So um,
alright.
So yeah,
this is great.
This,
uh,
this first one,
this was really shortly after coming to
work with you guys.
I want to say it was maybe the second
episode that I ever did,
um,
which was such a treat because it was
the episode we did with the CFO,
which,
you know,
I'd like legend.
I had grown up watching jackass.
I love that shit.
And um,
and you know,
a week into this Gig,
you know,
getting into,
hanging out with Steve all day.
It was like this is pretty cool.
And so back then we did the ad reads
live and I can't believe we ever did
that crazy.
Uh,
so they did the ads live and then,
you know,
you guys wanted to take a break to use
the restroom and he was like,
oh,
I'm good.
And it's like,
well,
you know,
you can hang out and I think we had like
an ipad or something with the twitch
chat going.
And so,
uh,
he saw somebody in the twitch chat say,
Hey,
what's,
uh,
what's your craziest drug story?
And immediately he launches into fucking
wild story about a time at like,
cause you know,
he's clean now.
He doesn't do any of this,
but he was just,
you know,
this was maybe 10 years prior.
I don't think I ever watched this back.
Oh,
well this is my first time.
I actually have it timestamped to the
moment.
You guys walked back in.
Here we go here.
The whole story.
Yeah.
That's fucking watch.
I've never watched it.
It's our own content for Christ sake.
Yes.
Since you're my best drug story.
Oh my God,
I can't.
I tell,
I'll tell you,
my God fucked up.
He's alone in the room.
You know,
I thought about asking him that
question,
but I was like,
should we get set all the time?
You know,
but
I was reading that it just wasn't
fucking funny.
I'm going to shut this door now.
What a professional.
Yeah,
I know was so helplessly addicted to
cocaine.
It was insane.
Like if I ran out,
I would call this drug dealer.
And uh,
I was waiting for a call from him.
I'd be like,
dude,
using my cell phone as a pillow so that
when it vibrated,
Meghan would wake up,
be like,
oh yeah,
and new drugs.
Now if I went to a event,
I caught up the drug dealer and he
didn't answer,
I would just fucking show up at his
place.
I would just go there.
And you're like,
ah.
When I got to his place,
our,
our Ed try the door.
Sometimes it was open and I would just
walk in and sometimes it wasn't open and
that was upsetting.
Um,
this guy,
okay.
This drug dealer wasn't just a drug
dealer.
He was also like a hardcore addict.
And when I can,
and I'm talking about cocaine,
this guy would inject cocaine.
He would shoot up and for some reason
never injected anything.
Yeah.
Some reason that I just don't understand
about people who shoot up cocaine is
that with their syringe,
they scored their own blood all over the
planet.
I mean,
this guy's apartment and it was all
like,
I don't think that's normal sativa
sealing the furniture this motherfucker
had to.
His with syringes,
what squirt all over the place.
Blood I showed up and I would walk in.
I'd find the guy like sitting there with
like literally needles fucking hang out.
I felt like it was hanging out of his
neck one time.
You're sitting there and I walked in.
He was like,
oh,
hey,
what's up dude?
What's up bro?
Like a fuck.
It was gnarly.
And um,
you know,
I didn't.
Whatever.
I wouldn't judge him.
I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
hey man,
I only got to give me some coke.
I would buy like a bunch,
you know,
like I'm kind of so I can always buy
like quite a lot and I'm fucking time.
I showed up at his door was not,
it wasn't,
it wasn't locked and it was open.
I walked in,
it wasn't in the living room.
He was in his back bedroom.
It was like a guest house kind of a deal
and it wasn't like an apartment,
but it was,
it was like a guest house.
He went through the back of someone's
driveway and then he was,
he was in the back and I walked in.
So he's in his bedroom,
in the back and like,
the dude's like,
he wasn't dead obviously,
like,
but he was not responsive,
you know,
he was so he had been awake for so many
days that there's no fuck awakened this
guy up.
And he's like,
I'm like trying to wake him up yet and I
need fucking drugs,
you know,
like he's using,
there's no getting this guy up.
So,
so thought man,
like I just finally was like,
okay,
fuck,
you know,
he's just sleeping so I'm just not going
to get them up.
So I went myself into his living room to
the table where he would weigh out all
of his drugs and there was from him
weighing.
So this guys sold so much fucking drugs
that,
that on the table itself,
there was just like a fucking residue of
coke has built up.
And I'm looking at it like I knew that
if I took a car that uh,
that I could just,
I could scrape up like the gnarliest
pile of cocaine.
And I'm just like,
I'm just going to go.
I want drugs.
I'm just,
fuck,
I'm going to go fucking hell my sub to
go scrape.
So now I go and I sit down at the table
where and I'm looking at it,
there's cookie cookie and all over it.
But like I said,
the motherfucker squirted his own blood
everywhere so it's like cooking with
blood,
like little bladders,
like thin,
like you know,
and I'm like fuck is a terrible idea.
There's just this is fucking bad.
And I'm like.
And I just start scraping on fucking
cooking and like I can like visibly,
like in the pilot I'm scraping like it.
I can see specks of blood on this.
This is how fucking bad.
I was addicted.
Sad there.
Like a fucking snorted them
motherfuckers blood to ask me for my
craziest drug story.
That was on my.
I wanted to ask you,
the bad is dry.
I just dropped the CBO is an incredible
storyteller.
Sober.
No,
it looks really healthy.
Really healthy and it looks like he was
reacting to people in the room,
like making eye contact with me.
You had talked about how he used to see
cigarette.
Yeah,
but while I was kept,
that was,
that was like four minutes.
I never knew I had my mind.
I was always like,
snore,
blood Wimax,
when that whole thing as like,
what's the setup,
would there you have it?
Well,
I'm glad I didn't realize you guys
hadn't seen it at all.
So I'm glad we,
uh,
we got to review that.
Yeah.
And like you guys,
like I said,
you had gone out to the bathroom,
so I'm just sitting in that other room
and my jaw was dropped.
This is telling the story.
I'm like,
is he fucking for real right now?
So,
uh,
so that was pretty wonderful.
Launched.
I watched the documentary but steevo
during those early years.
And he was,
he was wild.
He was not,
not well,
that was all serious.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I don't doubt that at all.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so that was definitely a,
a great early memory of working with.
Yeah,
that was episode 12,
the podcast,
and I think I had come in on 11 so that,
you know,
that was my second episode.
Went from Joey Salads to having stable
on the one end to the other right there.
So then actually my next uh,
was,
was also the Martin Shkreli thing.
Um,
so we've already,
we've already gone down that rabbit hole
a little bit.
Uh,
what else do we got here?
Um,
all right.
This is,
don't,
don't judge me is a little corny,
but this is not one of my favorites.
Yeah.
So the podcast,
I've got a little announcement,
not really an announcement,
just something I wanted to talk about
and just to give some context.
You guys didn't tell us either like
something was up,
but this,
I,
I found out the same time as all of you.
So,
uh,
so this was a pretty special moment,
but it may be that.
And also the delivery is hilarious.
There's a new thing of the thickening
was going to be thickening up here soon.
What does that mean?
What I'm trying to say is that Isla
won't be drinking alcohol.
So if she's responsible what I'm trying
to say.
Podcast extra.
Oh,
how long was that going?
it just started,
like you turned it off immediately.
Flashed red,
they're like,
no,
he lives.
There's two stripes.
She's cooking something up.
It's a cinnamon roll with Ross Standard.
Isla.
It's weird.
She's 11.
I think we literally found out the day
we couldn't keep it.
Well it's,
we,
we don't know yet if anything's gonna go
wrong.
She's pregnant.
So I just say,
you know,
because
that's very sweet of you Dan.
That genuinely was.
That was the specialists are warming.
Yeah.
Well she is.
The thickening has happened.
Can you show like over just do like a
tight,
like make your shirt tight.
Oh,
look at the camera.
Let me see what we can see it on the
wall.
It's hard to tell,
but when there was a bomb,
it's funny because you're like halfway
through and you.
I mean these next four months are going
to go fast.
Exhilarates celebrate from here on out.
Yeah.
No,
but I was sought isla the other day when
she was getting dressed or like just
yesterday and as she's putting a shirt
on,
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
there's a baby in there.
Yeah,
no,
it's weird.
Yeah,
that's great.
And then,
uh,
this I'll make,
I had a few more,
but I'll make this my last of my
favorite.
Um,
this is to this day,
my favorite line that's ever been
uttered on this podcast.
I don't think it'll ever be topped,
honestly.
I'm curious.
What is it?
So 39 with post Malone looks so
exhausting.
It is.
I looked like shit.
Now you look in the.
You're killing it,
bro.
I love that.
You just.
The great thing is that you just embrace
your authentic dude.
You're who you are.
Like you just fucking.
You're killing it,
bro.
I'm just a guy.
Exactly.
Just to kind of beautiful blue eyes.
Right?
I guess that means you are more than
just a gun because I didn't have that.
I'm really just the guy.
Your eyes look like hamburgers.
Yeah.
That is amazing.
That's so fucking funny.
But I think of that regular.
That's a very original line.
And they do export village.
Your eyes are like blueberry and want to
eat them.
That Tom Petty Song write a brown eyed
girl than Morrison.
Van Morrison.
Marsha,
that was quick.
I'm right on that.
But famously a post malone as a new
track coming out on his new album called
hamburger.
I'd about me.
That's awesome.
Congrats.
Um,
okay.
And then,
uh,
and then I just have one worst moment
that I need to put up there.
I'm legitimately still have nightmares
about this.
Occasionally.
That's not a joke.
I'll have like stress nightmares about
work and we are streaming.
God,
this was our first on youtube on
youtube.
Come over and see what it feels like
because we've never actually watched
from the show.
And so I thought it'd be a fun
experience to see that one point.
2 million views on today's episode.
I can't believe people watch this.
It keeps me going for like over a
minute.
Isla,
you are looking good and Dan is
screaming at the end.
I can't hear him on twitch.
You can do appreciate working here.
And then I know I'm in this little minor
escape that I never want to know.
What happened,
which made this so great,
is that it was our first live episode on
Youtube,
which means that because we were live
streaming on twitch,
so if we had a mistake like this,
we could just start over.
Right.
And then cut it up.
So this was the first time that it was
like when you got to actually nail this
live and I think part of it too is that,
you know,
I usually double check all the computers
and would check for this kind of stuff,
but because it was the first time on
Youtube I had a million new,
like it wasn't routine,
like it was the first day of the new
setup and so my mind was a million
places and didn't see that you had
stream open.
Whoops.
Hey look,
we got one point,
2 million views.
Yeah,
I guess it's worked out.
Somehow people powered through that
makes me feel better.
At one point 2 million people have seen
me feel better.
I give to hard on yourself then.
Yeah.
Well you know,
you.
Especially if you have an anxiety attack
on camera.
Yeah,
exactly.
It wasn't a disaster.
It sounds like an anxiety attack.
Then after that episode we go and we see
how bad is it?
Like,
oh,
we're like,
how bad could it be?
And it keeps going and it keeps going.
You guys,
when I told you I was,
you were like,
you know,
after the episode it was like,
hello,
how bad is it?
And it was like pretty bad.
Well,
it's fun.
It's funny in retrospect as to I guess,
but um,
but yeah,
I mean I'll,
I'll sometimes have like just this past
week.
Yeah,
it was the night before the charity
stream.
Not,
I didn't dream about that,
but I had a dream that our audio board,
all the settings got erased like five
minutes at a horse show,
which anybody that's done audio would
know that that's like,
you know,
two hours of reset that would need to
happen.
And so I'm glad to know you're having
nightmares about what it means.
You really care.
I do the next day or whatever.
Naked.
So cherished memories,
cherished memories and not so cherished
memories.
So yeah,
so that was,
that was my lineup and we got.
We got him in here.
Why don't you guys switch seats?
I left my soda and the other room.
Oh sure.
This is not so many Saudis.
Saudi paps could.
Oh,
I see where it is.
Yeah,
you should just be the list.
Right.
Gotcha.
Dead Air.
So this one was Dan.
Let's listen to it.
Early on when I started working here.
And this moment I think took us all
caught us all by surprise.
Bradbury showed up.
Wait,
hold on.
What is this clip?
But only it's 2000 views.
This is way early on the channel.
The highlight channels.
One of the first no videos,
that highlight channel is going to be
the lowest by the way.
Highlight channel.
Just hit a million subscribers.
That is so cool because we all created
that highlight channel together less
than a year ago because people were
stealing our clips and posting it,
sort of like what the hell we should do
it.
Right.
And uh,
the explosion there has been phenomenal
and it's so cool that we've all built
that together.
You guys were all here from the
inception of that channel,
actually cut it,
cut the highlights and low 75 percent.
Again,
a lot of credit there.
He is the highlight king and I handled
some of the slick thumbnails now.
The thumbnails had been fired lately.
Our thumbnail game has been improving.
Yeah,
you guys got acquired talent.
You're getting better and better at it,
but that's our fourth million
subscribed.
Right?
Pretty soon.
Another button now the button can pawn
off.
What were you going to say?
And we did a toast that I feel like I
peaked a little bit ago with Papa John
Shooting Papa John in the back of the
head.
I don't know if that was ever done.
Was really something.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh,
we testing.
Are we doing this?
Should we test one?
Ian's done.
We can.
Well,
let's,
let's enjoy some orange soda while you,
uh,
I don't want because you mentioned that.
So as Ian Discusses his,
um,
is a best and worst we shall enjoy.
Is this crystal what year?
Vintage?
A few thousand dollars.
Because I don't know who drinks orange
soda.
It's probably been sitting on the shelf
for about that long rosé right?
Or is this your style?
Rosacea?
This is a.
What is this?
Squirt Fanta.
Nice Fruity Aroma and picking me up
here.
Go ahead and give you drink.
You can have a little of that since you
are pregnant,
but not too much.
That's probably true about soda.
They're like,
don't drink that shit if you're
pregnant.
Got To let it open up.
Yeah,
let it.
Let it.
Let it air out a little bit.
I want to dive right in to that.
Cheers guys to 1 million on the.
On the.
On the highlights,
highlights and so a greater first 100
episodes together.
Yes indeed.
And thank you to all the viewers and
listeners.
I think that turned really tastes
fucking online.
Does Sarah and Zach has a cup in the
back?
Are you guys doing this?
We did a little backstage.
Was Sara.
Cheers guys.
Look great to year to a great
celebration of,
you know,
there's six people here that I really
like.
I guess that includes five.
I'll let you decide.
Count like,
wait who?
But who's left down by?
Not including myself.
Oh,
okay.
Office.
Wait.
Why are we confused about.
No,
we're not going to send it,
right?
Yeah.
Six.
Okay.
If you had said you had said the wrong
number and then left us includes you.
Right?
It's weird to say,
I really like.
I didn't mean to say that.
Do people really like themselves?
I don't love yourself.
I know people say that.
Yeah.
I mean nobody.
It's weird to be like say,
okay.
Regardless.
He hit us,
hit us with them names.
I remember we were all panicking on this
one because we had no idea what was
going to walk through the door.
If Ethan Bradbury,
we're going to just be like completely
quiet.
They're going to engage and then they
turned out to be just absolute legends.
There's a little back story actually
because we didn't know what to expect.
And um,
somebody rolled outside to greet them.
Was it un?
Uh,
it wasn't me.
I think we saw out the window actually,
isn't it?
I don't think you could see where
somebody went outside.
I think,
and maybe it was me,
it was me.
It was definitely me.
I went out to go meet them and I saw
them in the parking lot putting on the
spiderman that's and I was like,
oh my God.
I came inside and I was like,
oh my God,
you guys are going to remember this?
Oh yeah.
I remember like we bought donuts before
and make it their own.
They were,
they were.
They knew what was up.
They came to play,
so we rolled out the carpet form here.
I think the only guest that ever got the
red carpet treatment,
by the way,
why?
I love the exact shot into the office or
something,
Kinda played the kids music.
We were all obsessed with ethan trap
area as I still am.
Actually.
Shout out to Cole songs,
does his own thing.
I was afraid that I was afraid that
she's going to lay on the couch and it's
like,
oh shit.
One of the guns come on my mind.
I was like Spidey,
such a clean up this damn city guys.
That was a good moment.
Yeah,
that was pretty great.
They were very,
very onboard.
Surprise,
surprise you.
That was the beginning of the turn,
the paradigm shift in the life of Ethan
Bradbury and Joe and mo Jo Malone
Bradbury,
because since then they've gotten full
me mode to get complete extreme and now
they comment on every instagram post
that any of us ever made.
Since that episode.
They will miss a single day.
Don't miss the boats.
They do not miss a post,
and he always said he ethan wrights
stuff that doesn't even make sense.
He'll just go like slamming on
everything.
It's just,
it's great.
God bless his soul.
You know,
sometimes.
I mean,
I remember when you made the
announcement,
he actually was pretty sweet with his
comment.
That's true.
Yeah.
What did he say?
It was just congratulating.
You seem very real.
Congratulations.
There wasn't a slamming.
Slamming me.
We've got the profit.
Yeah.
This was when a doctor showed up,
looked so good.
Professor prophecies.
Got To make a comeback.
So this is when you introduced the Doc.
He's someone who I respect and
appreciate and I'm also going to take
them out three times and I'm the prof
and I'm here to profit the end of the
dark.
Dan Bring this coward,
coward in county through is to look at
this coward.
How have a seat,
because I'm the three times three time
world champ.
90 seven 98.
He's so fucking tall.
Three time,
dude.
Yeah,
minecraft casual gaming.
Okay.
First of all,
I have a castle in minecraft.
If my bullies didn't come into my server
and tearing down,
you wouldn't be in an off.
I replicated the TNG enterprise in
minecraft and you're going to shit on
that.
That's why they call me the three times
I did bring you some collector item tee
shirts and I don't know if I even want
to him to you.
Now you've got a fat girl,
a girl.
Take a look at.
Take a look at it.
Frankly.
I can't see you.
I'm to.
I'm going to put these down.
You can't see it in the Google prototype
scopes with originally got here.
That was good.
That was really fun.
Yeah,
that was just a fun.
That was one of my favorite episodes.
I think he was just so entertaining.
I was so nervous about interviewing and
because he's so deep in character that
it was just.
I was afraid was gonna be a minefield of
trying to get him to say anything
interesting,
but he actually,
he,
he did great.
I mean he never broke character but,
but he still managed to be kind of real.
The Lens of the character.
It was,
it was good.
Yeah,
I enjoyed that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so another one that I had was when we
had sean,
Sean Evans,
first gotTa chew you gotTa fucking beard
and everything.
Yeah.
When I saw this I was like,
oh yeah.
You and Alex were getting creamed in the
background.
It was,
it was rough.
I was not anticipating while I was at
the time because you now like spicy food
because of this.
Right.
Look,
this kinda like broke the seal.
I remember it was,
we knew this about Ian that he like
never ate spicy food and then we forced
like a hot cheeto would knocked me on my
end.
So you know,
this was a big jump,
but this was so fun because the taste is
kind of pleasant at first.
It feels like I was teabag by Satan.
It looks like you were to back,
let's say,
are you filling out crying?
I was dying back there.
That was rough.
I was so fun.
That was one of my favorite episodes
because we have always been such fans of
hotlines.
And then to get actually got to pick his
brain a little bit on how he interviews
people.
Um,
that was actually,
I think the first time I showed my face
on the deal,
we had the meme where we never saw your.
Although we didn't really never shut
like we've shown blown at once before.
I think the.
Or it was made by Joey Salad,
a joey in his blog.
He showed somebody on the subway.
I was such an ancient.
Me.
I almost don't even remember.
Now you're eating the powerpoint is the
pace of the show at this.
Basically we gave everyone had to deal
with this,
but yeah,
I really.
That was great.
Doing a little mini hartland.
Yeah,
that was cool.
Another I liked when Eric brought on his
conspiracy closet segment broker clip.
Oh yes.
I love,
love.
Love this real quick.
So keep an eye on now.
This guy's a clone,
he's about the glitch,
the fuck out.
A certain amount of distance between the
two on the right might also be clones.
There is a lot.
It's a big day or do the strangest
things on his.
On the history of what is happening.
If you could say there's a pretty big
weight go
because she's like,
and it's such a weird face that it's not
a natural relaxed look.
Yeah.
It's so weird,
but it does seem like somebody said like
his trigger word and he went into debug
mode from them.
I think the second off,
it's true.
Oh yeah,
they intro.
This segment is just so great.
No.
Whether we should get another episode
going of ABC's until.
That would be fun,
man.
Eric is always a blast to avalon.
Yeah,
he's a great president.
It's time to reboot the conspiracy
classes.
Yeah.
I didn't know it meant that much to you,
but,
but know to this day people constantly,
but I'll see comments like please bring
it back.
It was so good.
Yeah,
we should.
I really love how he prepared a segment.
It was,
it really worked.
And uh,
this was the,
another squirelly one,
but this was just to show the live
episode we did,
which I thought was one of the funniest,
most enjoyable ones we've done,
but also extremely stressful,
you know?
Oh yeah.
You guys,
you guys in the crew.
I mean that was,
it took so much work and you guys were
grinding hard.
It was all of that together.
We had extra because it wasn't just do
the live show is also streaming it,
recording it all the first time ever
doing it out of our studio,
which I've done a lot to promote events.
So that was my job before I came and
worked for you guys.
But it had been awhile and I was used to
working with like a production truck and
like,
you know,
and,
but uh,
but we pulled it off.
Maybe get closely with them on any
hitches.
Really.
I will say the projector was a pain in
the audio was fucking out of it.
We're kind of Improv.
Why do you guys have a $50 fucking
projector?
Just barely got time on the stage to get
used to it now where before,
but that's all right.
We got kicked out of the venue.
Yeah.
There were some circumstances that made
it.
For the most part,
it was as smooth as you could hope for.
But Zach was calling in as Jordan the
fanboy.
Yeah.
And he was coming the projector.
That's right.
Yes,
very much.
Now I have nightmares about that one
too.
I wasn't in control because we tested it
beforehand.
I don't work.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's only so much you can do a.
It was a such a fun,
such a fun,
fun time and so stressful.
It was just too stressful.
That's what we haven't done it again
because we were like,
that was amazing and I never want to do
it again.
Kind of.
We did one and do it again,
but we don't want to.
It's.
It's weird.
We even had the idea of doing it once a
month.
I don't know.
Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
Doing it as kind of a residency thing.
I mean if we were maybe something
considering the future because if we do
it regularly then it becomes less of a
thing,
you know,
you got a routine on how you do it and
you get into a rhythm and it's not so
bad.
So maybe someday in the future.
I mean it was so fun.
It really was fun.
We all went out afterwards this out and
like that.
That was super fun.
But the,
the,
the thing is like in the room that there
was so much laughter and joy in the room
and everyone,
there were some really great energy,
but when you watch the vod you don't
really get to feel that because you
don't hear the laughs and the crowd as
much as we did in the room.
Which that was another aspect is we,
the venue did the audio and not that
they did a terrible job,
but they didn't necessarily have a
audience mics.
And so,
you know,
if we were to do it again,
lesson learned like the Mike,
we should,
we should.
Yeah.
Maybe we'll do another one next year.
It was.
Oh,
and there was a proposal of marriage,
but you know what,
we buy them again.
We went.
When we did kill Tony,
they were in the audience.
Oh,
no way.
And they came and said Hi.
We're like,
you guys are married now.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Trying to find the moment,
but yeah,
look at this guy is big.
He's bragged.
Judgment just came out with this.
Damn that audio quality is seven years.
This ties it all together here.
I suspect if he wasn't such a troll he
probably would be fine.
Setting it up,
playing a little meme that it's going to
be nervous.
Post was,
I know a giant crowds,
but this is a different vibe.
But you had everybody lift up their cell
phones.
Yeah,
look at that.
Great.
California kind of these pretty precious
animals.
That's why we care so much about Bombay.
So we had danny come into actually had
cam.
Awesome.
Really well shot.
If you could make $100,000,000
to go to jail,
how much time would you do?
Is this related to your situation?
Totally over a hundred million dollars
right now.
I'm looking at a zero to six months,
six months and no fine.
It's so cold.
He lived the same way.
He was locked up,
meaning you can already lost last
special round of applause.
Good job.
It was amazing.
You feel so funny because like you have
such a sympathetic audience,
right?
And they're there for you and they love
you.
So it's like,
it's the best fucking crowd.
I can only imagine trying to perform
like the phone.
Oh my God.
I wish.
I can only imagine trying to do jokes
for people who don't know who you are.
Tough game out there.
Tough game.
I think Sarah and put this one in the
best or favorite moments or one of her?
Least favorite.
Actually,
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
What is the thank you.
Once again,
a dead mouse.
George Zimmerman.
I remember thinking this is why I
haven't
straight up name phobia.
That's the.
I had it before that.
When I say people's name,
I get so stressed that I'm going to say
the wrong thing.
I had like a mini panic attack every
time and I called him George Zimmerman,
George Zimmerman.
But right one,
we were closed and the new album is
coming out and fucking
George Zimmerman because that's Florida.
Who killed a dude,
man.
That's funny as shit guys.
Got It.
Got It,
got it.
Wow.
Oh Man.
Great entry was one of them.
One of my worst moments I think.
Wait,
those are condos.
Yeah.
So you won't go to his listening party
where his fucking can go anywhere.
Right here.
I got him on stock X.
I love shoes it and that way you can say
it,
but I buy,
I buy the shoes that I really genuinely
like.
And are those puffy you have?
Very.
Yeah.
Kanye west shoes or fucking,
you know,
our,
our intern has fake easy song.
Really.
Got It.
I got to tell you,
I was on the back happened.
He was legitimately crushed.
I felt like I was out.
It took me out of the closet.
I thought it was still new,
like the was.
I thought it was like an interesting
point of conversation to note like,
but then I was like,
oh I shouldn't have.
Because I forget that you're so in the
Kanye community.
Yeah.
But did you feel betrayed?
I guess so.
I'm always like a rat in the community.
Like I was banned from the floor.
I couldn't get the real.
I'm like screwing around in the walls,
but Kanye fans so you know.
But well okay,
because there is a silver lining to
that.
What you're wearing right now as a
result,
as the outing in Adidas reached out
and hooked in up.
No one else.
No.
So we're all gel.
Actually.
Let me riff,
let me rephrase.
They said we want to give you guys the
eecs who's up first and I said it's got
to be.
And in fact they haven't sent this
anymore,
you know,
it was difficult.
But we did get a pair and I am very
grateful for that.
So what,
so let me ask you this,
would you,
are you happy that I added you or would
you prefer to go back and erase that
moment?
Well either way I have yeezys like where
I'm not added.
Those are real everybody.
So it's a win win,
you know,
it's a zero sum game,
but I guess I have real ones now.
You had real ones,
but they're not real.
Let me ask you this.
Are the real ones more comfortable than
the fake ones?
It's a different.
He's different material,
but how does it compare because you've
got fake think are pretty comfy.
Um,
I think they're,
yeah,
they're comfier than the fake ones for
sure.
If the right thing to say.
Yeah.
And I,
and now I'm glad.
I'm not going to find.
I'm convinced now that his shoes are
more available than,
you know,
there's no need to buy the fake ones.
So if you see me in any other pair of
the real,
I don't look at,
don't get too close.
Very real easy.
Bus is going to be all open.
But those were my,
uh,
all of my moments best and worst.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's it.
That was fun.
Let's see what else we got here.
Wow.
Seen it all.
We've done it at all.
It was nice to remember two hours.
Wow.
That's a lot of talk about,
you know.
Well,
we've got one other.
Do we,
are we going to take that call in from
debunker real.
Oh,
let me go get it.
While you're preparing that,
I have a fan submission.
Remember you can always submit to
podcast at h three,
h three productions.com
if you have any question.
Submissions is we want to,
you want us to watch,
etc.
But this one can be
best and worst moments.
People suBmitted a lot and it was very
hard.
That was amazing.
Thank you guys.
But this one comes from jay dance in
regards to our charity live stream and I
thought it was,
it was very sweet and addressed one of
the points we were wondering about.
So here,
I'll read it a hello everyone at the age
three.
My name is j.dance
and I'm a huge fan of the podcast and
got into podcasting because of you guys.
I'm writing you guys today,
um,
because of the charity event podcast you
guys did yesterday with justin rolland
and alex hirsch.
I'm from paradise,
California and most of my family friends
have lost everything due to the
campfire.
I just want to say thank you for doing
this charity podcast.
It means so much to all of us.
The suPport and help.
And then she goes on.
Oh,
and one more thing you guys should,
you guys talked about,
um,
one more thing you guys talked about
what you would take if you had a chance
to evacuate and most of you said dog,
of course the media has given backlash
towards people leaving their pets,
which on paper I would have to.
The truth is when the fire head
paradise,
it was around 8:00
AM,
8:30
so by that time most people had already
gone to work or school and drop their
kids off at school.
Paradise being a small town,
most people don't work in paradise and
mute out of town and the surrounding
cities like chico,
red bluff reading,
etc.
So when the fire hit paradise and when
it did hit it very quickly,
people did not even have the time to go
back to paradise to get their pets or
any personal belongings because it was,
you know,
I wanted to share this with you guys and
that does actually explain it.
Anyway,
thanks for being awesome people and I
always looking forward to the show.
Thank you so much jay dance.
So that actually puts it even more in
perspective because you go off to work
or school,
you don't even have a chance to get not
only your pet but any of your belongings
be so devastated.
If I couldn'T go take care of shredder
and you know that something's up
that makes art because I feel like a lot
of the videos I watched were people were
trying to drive back into it was because
of their pets and I did wonder that.
So yeah,
I mean god,
that's so heart wrenching.
Like to not to feel helpless like
shredders in the house.
Right.
And you don't know if it's on fire.
Like what?
Like I don't,
I would run into the fire.
I guess that's what some people will try
it.
I mean it's just like such a betrayal
and your poor pet is at home.
Scared,
confused looking for you.
That's so devastating.
I'm glad that this direct relief can
help anyone.
Right?
And just to revisit,
because dan is setting up a call with,
with a,
a person that paid a thousand dollars.
I want to urge you guys all link in the
description.
It's below the sponsors,
so just open it up and you'll find the
link there to remember that you can
donate for another 10 days to help
everybody who lost their homes in the
fire.
And this goes directly to support them.
There's so many incredible gifts still
available,
um,
some with,
with bid so low that you have an
incredibly high chance of winning it,
especially all the original art that I
would heavily urge you guys to go bid
on.
Let me see how we're doing.
Tilt the five
if you just go to [inaudible] dot com.
Rondo.
Oh,
nice.
Has been going up since we started live
streaming.
Um,
here we are at 1:30
till the rewards.
I'm telling you there's this shit is
just up for grabs.
All the original art is just like.
I think this one is the one that had 80,
80 bucks.
Is it an original alex hirsch?
Wait,
no,
not this one.
It was the original justin reuland
artwork by alex.
Oh god.
He got sloppier and sloppier.
No wonder nobody's betting on that.
$8.
Is that what it was?
I don't know which one to hear.
Hold on the one that's at $8.
Justin.
So funny.
God,
it's still adjusting reuland originally.
He doesn't make sense.
Why is it not letting me.
Oh,
this is really.
I'll tell you which one was eight bucks.
Here.
Let me give you the rundown.
If I can find it.
Can I find it original?
Alex?
You know,
it's the,
the eight bucks one is alex hirsch's
drawing of justin rayland,
which that deserves to come on people.
That was amazing.
Oh waiT,
where's the.
Oh,
I don't have the document.
I have it open right now.
So let me share it with ethan.
I wait.
I would like to it.
yeah.
That's weird.
So here we go.
Yes.
Oh,
it's not letting me
look at this shit.
I can't click the tab on the bottom.
It's hidden.
What do,
what do you want to know though?
I'm looking at it right now.
Okay.
So here we go.
Did you get the fan on the phone than I
do?
He's on hold.
So let's take the call.
Take the call now.
yeah.
Alright.
stand by.
I've got them in original.
Alex hirsch.
You should show all the crazy graphs
that sarah.
Oh yes.
Fucking ham on,
on the graph.
Look at that.
The one that I really like is the,
um,
this is like hourly donation rate.
So you can see when justin.
Justin rally.
Exactly.
We did.
We dipped so hard.
Wait,
that's at the end of the.
Okay.
That's the end.
So here we were hitting this mid point
and we're like,
man,
there's no way we're going to make it
where there's no way.
And then we were at like 75 here and
this was the rally demand in one hour.
That was actually our Biggest,
our of the whole stream finale killed
it.
he came in like brave heart.
Everyone.
Oh,
this is page two.
That's just how much each here's was
donated by ya.
Don't kill.
Sees this post.
Okay.
I better not.
I don't know what's best for this.
Both sarah.
But I'm scared you go to the spirit
realm if you clicked that.
Yeah,
that's right.
So let's patch.
So who we got on the phone here?
So,
uh,
this is a gentlemen who goes by fifths
and he's a fan.
He's a big fan of the podcast we watched
in a long time and he,
um,
during the donation stream donated a
thousand bucks when you did the shout
out to have a color,
a call land,
but he had an international number and
our phone system,
the phone system wouldn't let us get to
them and so we had kind of a technical
issue getting through to him.
So to make it up to him,
we're talking to them today.
So here is phipps,
right?
A resume call right now.
Fifths.
Hey,
what's up?
Hey you.
First of all,
thank you so much.
You've donated,
you helped us get to a 100,000.
Your legend.
I'm sorry we didn't get to answer your
call during that live stream,
but I am
the whole,
the whole gang.
It was really crazy.
The old podcast.
It wasn't about the cost specifically.
You guys are doing this for a great
cause and I really appreciate what you
guys are doing.
God bless.
Thank you so much,
man.
You're doing it.
I want to ask you,
since we're in the spirit of sharing our
favorite moments,
do you have a favorite moment that,
uh,
as I,
as,
as a,
as a audience member of the podcast,
I mean,
you guys pretty much covered a lot.
the ricky ticky tack,
he was calling the church and he was
going crazy with the boys.
I was like,
whoa,
calm down.
Like I didn't think that he would take
it that far.
I think it was like a little,
you know,
goof.
And then he Just stopped.
He just kept on going and I really love
it.
Yeah.
I was shocked watching that back today
actually.
How crazy that call was that later?
No,
it was just really awesome.
Like I really like,
the thing is,
is that what I love about the podcast
itself is that,
you know,
you guys have this kind of formula going
on,
but you diversify in a way that you have
always these new elements coming in.
So you have ruined in a couple of times.
Right?
But every time he comes in there's
something new added to the mix,
like new elements,
which is something as an audience member
like,
oh,
we shit,
you know.
Damn,
thank you.
That's awesome to hear you work hard.
It is.
Sometimes doesn't.
Maybe it's not easy to spot,
but we've,
I mean we try,
we work hard on the,
on the show and I,
and I'm glad to hear that,
that you appreciate it.
And we're working hard.
I think.
I'm hoping that um,
when we come back for like one slash one
plus the new season,
I want to call it in a month,
I want to redo a lot of things and kind
of reimagine what we do here and freshen
it up a lot.
I've got some fun ideas and I'm like,
well one thing we talked.
Oh go ahead.
What do you got for me?
No,
it was just asking you about like,
you know,
cause you have two channels,
right?
So you got a little bit of the criticism
about kind of like how you're balancing
up the channels and everything.
I don't only need to get into it too
much,
but like you're putting a lot of effort
into the podcast,
whIch is awesome,
but like how would you balance out that
effort with the main channel vh date?
She productions.
So I think a misconception that people
have is that my lack of uploads on h
three,
h three was due to me focusing my energy
to the podcast when the truth of why I
wasn't posting there had wasn't an issue
of time or commitment or anything like
that.
It was really a result of not knowing
what to do there or not feeling like I
was in the right head space or having a
lack of motivation or just a lot of
negative bad feelings around posting
there.
So for me it's a lot of people were
like,
oh,
he stopped posting there because the
podcast is more lucrative and he doesn't
care about his fans or whatever.
Again,
just kind of people always want to see
the worst in it and like just assume the
worst about people.
But the truth of the matter is,
and one that I'm addressing now as best
as I can,
is that I,
I am and was depressed.
I mean I'm doing much better now I
think,
and something that I'm working on,
but I had a lot of anxiety and a lot of
issues,
um,
that I needed to resolve and a lot of it
was manifesting itself through how I did
my work there in my primary source of
entertainment.
And so the podcast was honestly a way
for me to not disappear.
It was a way for me to stay present and
to still be working and to still share,
share my life and be with our,
with the people that want that want to
continue to watch us.
so for me the podcast was something to
do while I sorted that shit out and it's
been an incredible resource for me to
come here and be able to share my
thoughts and to not just disappear,
right?
Because that's not something I ever
wanted to do.
And so I,
again,
I just think it's a misconception
because now we're back posting videos
there and we're doing both and it's
fine.
I mean we're busier,
but it's good.
I like being busy and I like feeling
productive and
well I really appreciate that.
I think mental health is something
that's really not addressed a lot in the
media and the way that it is addressed.
That feels a little bit underplayed.
A,
it almost seems as if it's like a,
a capital brand capitalists brand.
It's almost like something with the
better health situation.
Everything.
I'm not going to pick it up again,
but the thing iS,
is that the way that you're taking it
very head on and seriously,
I think I can personally commend that.
I admire a few hurdles in my life as
well.
Uh,
but I feel as though also when you were
talking about,
you know,
kind of facing an impasse indian year a
uploaded,
because I remember like when ray William
Johnson stopped posting,
you said something along the lines of he
no longer feels gratitude and doing the
same thing over and over again.
So it got me thinking that if you keep
doing the same type of style,
the same formulaic technique,
a,
wouldn't you?
Would you feel like less intellectually
challenged by doing these videos?
Well,
the truth is that I think so much of an
even maybe what he's saying,
so much of the negative feelings that
you might feel is a symptom of a
depressive state and not actually an
expressive,
an expression of like your creative art
and that there's always a way to
challenge yourself and there's always a
way to make it fresh and interesting.
The fact is that when you're depressed,
you see everything through that lens.
And so something I've learned about
myself is that before I started actually
treating my depression with medicine and
therapy,
is that you try,
you scramble and scramble and try to
address your depression because you
don't.
You don't know or you haven't accepted
that you're depressed,
right?
So you're trying and in your Mind and in
your life to address all of these
different issues that,
oh,
that's why this and that's why that and
that's why this,
but the truth is you're never actually
addressing the root problem.
You're addressing symptoms but never the
root problem.
So when you're depressed and you don't
address that,
you're always looking for some answer
and you always to change.
And the sad thing about it is that
you're never going to fix it until you
address the root cause.
So for me,
now that I'm feeling better,
making videos is a wholesome thing and
I'm content doing it.
Where before I was always looking for
something else,
I was like,
I need to make a show.
I need to work on the podcast more.
I need to get off you.
I need,
I need to do all these other things.
But those were never the answer.
Those were just me looking in vain for
something to make me feel better because
I didn't actually understand.
But now that I'm in a better place,
I can see that this is a good place for
me.
And it is a whole someplace for me and
If you want to express yourself
creatively,
there's always a room within the formula
you've created to,
to find a good,
wholesome,
productive,
happy place.
It's just a matter of coming at it
through the light lens.
I mean,
it really is a half glass,
a glass half full half empty thing and
when you're depressed it's sad is sadly
is always half empty and you really just
can never see the flip side of it.
And so
the perspective is very difficult to see
in a positive light.
Yeah,
I completely agree.
So I want to make this a little bit.
Uh,
I didn't mean to drag the mood down,
never mind it.
All the good questions.
I'm happy to talk about it.
You didn't drag it on if people were
wondering the same thing.
So it's good actually to talk
good about it.
And since you know,
we're,
we're in the spirit of bringing up
things at the end of the year.
I thought maybe it would be a little
nice mentioned,
mentioned some of your best moments in
terms of videos on hd productions.
Right?
I really love the a gold digger.
It was,
it was honestly a really nice highlight
for me because,
you know,
I mean,
all you did was literally say,
you know,
the,
the guys just fucking following the
woman.
The woman was being completely honest,
which is exactly true.
And the thing is that repetition was,
was the highlight of the whole video
with it's the same thing over and over
and over again.
The cracks me up every single time,
honestly.
Well,
that's awesome.
Thank you so much.
That was a great one.
That's great.
Yeah,
I liked it because it was,
it was a little bit of a twist because I
kinda resent all the gold digger content
you see on youtube.
I always thought it was just so
ridiculous.
And um,
when you finally get to see inside this
quote unquote gold digger relationship,
you realize that he's the flyer and
she's completely honest about her
expectations in the beginning and he's
the one that mess.
Let her.
Right.
That was kind of a funny twist on the
whole narrative of the gold digger.
Yeah,
no.
And uh,
honestly,
the thing is,
is that it's.
People look at things like specifically,
you know,
she's a gold digger,
she wants money.
That's a negative thing.
He's the victim.
Well,
I mean,
yeah.
Well she said she's just literally
saying that doesn't make it negative.
It's negative when you're trying to
deceive someone,
not just achieve an objective was being
hunches that,
hey,
this is what I want.
Can you give it to me?
Period?
Just gave it to me right there.
Right.
I don't even think she ever even
pretended to love him and he's also an
interest for her looks.
Yeah.
He wants her finger that wants to date a
pretty girl,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's.
I mean it's her hustle,
hustle,
her,
and then the first of all,
the 90 day thing,
it was never meant to work out.
It's never about.
It's 99.
He's watching this show and that show is
heating season.
Starting in so deep into data happening
is unimaginable.
People are saying it's the
darkest season ever and they're
abandoning the show,
but I'm totally suck then.
No,
I heard that.
That guy,
the guy from the show got arrested
or they charge and I plug in.
I called it too because in the show he's
the guys walking around with backpacks
of weed,
you know,
and then,
and then a couple months later they're
like,
oh,
we're in legal trouble.
And I was arrested for having tons of
weed and sure enough,
he's in prison right now and it's pieces
probably.
Oh,
she's been like lifting weights.
You've seen her.
She's all armed georgie.
Boy,
look,
if you're going to flex about business,
I mean,
come on,
what do you expect to happen?
You're going to
tv.
And the funny thing is that he's a drug
dealer that's not even that rich like
kid.
If you're going to do drugs,
at least be richer than that.
There's two levels of pathetic,
right?
There's,
there's,
you know,
the crummy drug dealing,
yada,
yada.
But then there's,
you know,
pretending to be a successful one at
that to pretend to be a successful
loser.
you know,
that's just,
it.
Just pick it for me like that.
And honestly,
I just wanted to also tell you that,
you know,
your commentary style,
everything you've done for the past
high.
No,
I don't have the exact number of years,
but you've been doing.
It's really awesome.
it kind of pushed me to start my own
youtube and everything.
So I had a little,
a few questions before I do my shameless
plug in.
Before I get there,
I have some genuine questions for you.
So what,
since we're at the end of the year,
this is also kind of a little did
retrospective,
what first motivated you to make these
videos?
Um,
well I knew that I wanted to work in
comedy for a long time Just because it
was something I was always passionate
about,
but I Really never,
I didn't have any connections.
I didn't know anyone and I didn't have
any experience making comedy.
So um,
I think I've mentioned this before but,
but well either we made a couple of
videos for els class and it was really
fun and I,
And I actually thought I had a knack for
it even though they weren't good or
they're very weird,
but I really enjoyed the process.
So for me it was kind of started as just
a creative outlet and kind of honing my
craft and figuring out my style and I'm
just slowly turned into having a youtube
channel,
which is funny because when we started
making youtube videos I didn't even know
you to being a youtuber was a thing.
I am,
we just posted it there but we didn't
know like,
yeah,
it,
it was just basically a hobby that
somehow slowly started turning into
something serious.
But I guess she had had some kind of
continuous motivation at the beginning
of youtube.
The idea of monetization was just this
abstract,
you know,
far away thought.
Right.
So you were doing it based on personal
ambition,
personal,
I guess ambition to succeed in this
industry which is youtube.
Well,
my original idea was that I was like
making a portfolio because at best I
thought,
hey,
I could be a writer or something for
comedy.
So I was just thinking of youtube as a
stepping stone of kind of just building
a portfolio and honing my craft and just
as a hobby to do that,
I don't have anything better to do.
So I,
I was thinking of it in the beginning as
a portfolio,
something like that and be like,
hey,
if I could make a couple of funny
videos,
then maybe I can get a job somewhere.
I made a lot of people from college
humor.
That's what they did,
you know,
the,
uh,
it became writers at the daily show,
stuff like that.
I completely get you.
I'm fair enough,
I guess,
uh,
you know,
first of all,
I,
I know this is,
this is a little bit of a funny story
concerning your name.
I'm from Saudi Arabia and we have this
weird thing with the language.
Basically the letters and the numbers.
Some numbers because we have different
letters,
right?
It's an arabic.
So some letters are expressed witH
numbers and when I was trying to plug
your channel to everyone I guess in
school when I was a kid I would just say
h three,
h three and the thing is is that when
they read that it says everyone sounded
like,
you know,
like fat albert and it was so weird like
that alberta getting,
having a stroke or something or the
other.
So basIcally I was plugging it
everywhere and people thought I was
spasming.
How do you say it in like a
and what an arabic.
How do you say it?
What do you mean?
Like how were you saying it?
I said h three,
h three,
but I would send them
texts or read it.
So how would they read it?
They would say like bill cosby.
Memorable.
But yeah,
honestly you've been a great inspiration
to me.
I don't have anything else to say.
I just have a few messages I wanted to
say.
I hope you don't mind.
So you're calling right now from Saudi
Arabia.
Oh yeah.
I'm calling you guys from Saudi Arabia.
Interesting that you guys have a huge
fan base here.
Interesting how interesting.
I can tell you every country then,
is there anything weird
is going on with like politically like
um,
you can't talk about that.
Yeah,
I can talk to you about like,
well,
I can tell you some good stuff.
Can't tell you the best
stuff I can tell you about the uh,
you know,
uh,
they had the first concert with mixed
like,
you know,
the men and women used to be segregated
and that just,
they just had the first concert with
black ips.
David gets,
uh,
they,
they removed the segregation between men
and women,
whiCh is a huge thing.
Interesting.
Have you been,
have you been outside of Saudi Arabia?
Uh,
yeah,
totally.
I'm actually,
I studied in the uk.
I'm just back for christmas break and
uh,
you know,
I've been to,
I've been to New York,
I've been to boston,
I've been,
I mean for visiting,
I've been a lot around,
but you know this,
the government is pretty tight there,
right about like internet usage and
stuff.
I mean it's,
it's,
I guess porn does.
The only thing you can't use.
No wonder.
No wonder people.
I mean,
shit,
that's why people watch your videos,
man.
It's the next best thing.
So when we see a combine,
I did this.
It's not a joke,
you know,
you get the urge,
you can open your eyes.
You'll.
So let me ask you this.
Are people in Saudi Arabia getting all
are,
do they jerk off to like this like you
know,
or the video we made like the egg
sandwich video.
Is that like good for.
That's the top search.
That's the good kid in Saudi Arabia.
Is that what people be at all?
But you probably used the h three but
you use that.
You probably use a vpn,
right?
If you're trying to find some good shit.
Let's be real.
I mean in terms of upn usage,
it's not even like hidden like people
use vpn regularly because the thing is
that it used to be the case that like,
stuff like whatsapp call is banned.
It's not that you can't call people,
it was only band because the,
the,
the main conglomerate,
uh,
didn't want competition.
They just want to people.
It wasn't even like a censorship type of
deal.
Just didn't want any company,
but then they decided like let's just
have a.
What's it called?
Like a competent competitive market.
so you know,
just stay unblended and yeah.
What's up calls back?
That's a huge stride after a woman
driving.
I use whatsapp all the time to call
Israel.
I'm just imagining not porn.
I mean be.
I would definitely be on youtube.
There's some weird pornographic videos
on youtube that we always make fun of.
I would be there naked yoga.
I just see.
I just need all the seat,
a little bit of side boob and I'm coming
in my pants a little more sympathy for
them.
Oh you got,
you got,
you got what's it?
There'll be frank and maximo doing
videos and you want us to look for
the site?
That's enough.
They don't overlap.
I need both.
Give be both.
What have we got?
A filthy frank w,
w,
w.
Would that be good?
Come on into my pants at the thought of
it.
So what's your,
what do you want to plug your channel?
Yeah,
you were just going to do it I think.
Uh,
okay.
So first of all,
my friends really insisted that I say
this message,
so sophia gagliano supports and loves
you and shredder really wanting
sophia
and then there's the uh,
based on my channel is called
[inaudible] and it really,
if I.
Fs.
Yeah.
And the thing is.
and here's the thing before you guys
close the call,
because I've been talking too much.
I know.
Basically the thing is I,
oh,
I posted one fortnight critical critical
analysis,
which sounds very juvenile,
but I mean I wanted to upload another
video but I didn't get the chance quite
a but it's coming up in a few days.
Whatever the hell it,
if that means anything.
Uh,
but yeah,
you guys should follow it.
And uh,
yeah,
that's my hustled.
I hope you guys have good stream.
I hope.
I wish we did have a great stream and I
actually very appreciate you donating
and calling it actually interesting to
talk to somebody from Saudi Arabia to a
fan from there.
That's very cool.
We still keep in touch.
We should keep in touch because I like
that fresh perspective out there.
Although I don't know how much you can
talk about,
but it's very fascinated to connect with
somebody
so the world.
You guys have my email,
like another little interview whenever
you guys want.
Cool.
Well thank you for the thoughtful
questions.
Thank you for the donation.
Thank you for watching,
man.
We appreciate you.
And best of luck with everything you're
doing up a blessed show.
Appreciate ya.
What a treat.
Cool.
No porn,
no wonder thIs fucking guy's over there.
So like,
well maybe you should try it.
anything.
But you want me to like go.
I'm just,
I'm just saying
no fat.
There's a thing where I've gotten a lot
of emails since we talked about it.
Yeah,
that was a popular discussion.
Encouraging it.
So.
And then,
uh,
before I forget,
there was one other person,
not a call,
but just somebody that uh,
had donated a bunch of them.
We posit,
I think we actually did do the shout
out,
but he emailed me and he,
he should missed it.
So shouT out to motivation app.
Uh,
he donated it.
I think a 350 bucks on the stream and a.
Sorry,
we missed that,
sorry I missed you.
And uh,
just wanted to just give you some
acknowledgment,
uh,
that,
you did a good thing.
And so
thanks a lot man.
Thank you.
Well guys,
it's 2018 episode 100.
We've done it all.
We've seen it all.
We've been through the strikes,
the gutters altogether.
What a touching.
Beautiful thing.
Ilos pregnant.
Um,
ian's got real yeezys.
Golly,
what a year.
It's all,
it's all happened.
We've done it all.
If people watched it all,
I know they've stuck around,
but by golly,
you papa.
Bless it.
Little little fitbit troopers.
I love you guys,
mAn.
Thanks for sticking around.
I,
I hope that the show I'm committed.
I love this.
I'm committed to making a better to
becoming a better interviewer,
a better host,
putting together better show.
It's been great.
It's been a real experience for us.
And next year,
2019,
we've got a lot of plans,
a lot of ambition.
Very excited tO get back into it.
I'm going to take a month to recharge.
We're going to be making a lot of h,
three h,
three videos.
We're going to be focusing on that,
so tune in there.
I'm excited just to kind of focus on
that for a little bit,
which is something we haven't done on a
very long time.
We weren't excited about it for a long
time.
Exactly.
And I am.
I'm feeling I'm feeling motivated to
make videos there again for a while.
Um,
when we're back,
the first episode back is Michael
Stevens.
Vsauce on the.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
dan,
the 21st or 25th of January 25.
Um,
he's got a new car,
a season of minefield.
I'm sure we're going to have a ton of
stuff to talk about and the episode
after that.
Want to get a furry in here in costume
or too or too.
Yeah.
I've been seeing all your emails.
A furry community.
Dan's going to vet you guys.
I'm,
I'm going to read through them all.
We've been pretty buried with the
charity stream,
but we're,
you know,
we,
we see you and we're going to work on
engaging the furry community and I want
to thank the community and everyone
involved who rallied to raise so much
money for people who so desperately need
it.
I'm so proud of you guys.
Proud of the community.
I just,
and I'm just so thankful and so much
gratitude to as who stuck around through
thick and thin.
You know,
I've had a rough year of dead and I've
done and said are a lot of stupid shit
and some and I got a lot of shit for it
and you know,
it's tested me more than I've ever been
tested in my life and I'm,
as kendrick lamar said,
you know,
when shit hits the fan,
are you feel bad,
you know,
and um,
some.
And you guys are still in a lot of
people stuck around and fucked with us
even in the worst of times.
So what more could you ask for than
that?
Right.
[inaudible].
So I haven't been holidays.
Everyone.
Happy holidays.
Have a merry,
merry christmas.
Whatever you're doing out there.
I am not,
I do not have a warrant.
Christmas.
I'll say merry christmas.
Happy hanukkah and every goddamn,
every quanta.
Does anyone celebrate kwanzaa?
I don't.
They always say happy kwanzaa,
but I've never,
I've never known anyone to celebrate
kwanzaa,
but I'm not discriminate.
I'm just saying I didn't know if they
just throw that in there,
but happy kwanzaa,
you know,
everybody happy.
Whatever you ears.
God damn it.
Uh,
so we are going to be,
we're going to be going in there man.
H three time baby.
I'm excited and I,
I don't,
I don't know how to end this because I
am so just so sincerely grateful.
And it's been a wild year.
It's been a wild year.
The longest year.
It's been the longest year ever.
Two thousand 18.
It's the longest year ever.
For me.
It was just pure for me.
Peer length of your.
I've heard a lot of people say that I
feel both.
I feel like it's.
Well imagine it's long,
but it's also short,
like it's already december.
It's over.
Let me pay 19.
Yeah,
but let me put it in.
Let me put it in context for you.
Let me see.
what were we doing around the beginning
of the year?
Let me tell you what episode we're doing
to kind of put it in context.
Um,
first one,
first one was a check and erica.
Oh,
this year that was,
we went to Israel to get.
Remember?
That does seem like in 10 years ago.
Yeah.
Oh,
in while you were in Israel,
the Logan Paul incident happened first
aid for each video back.
Oh.
So it's weird.
Some things feel short and things seem
like it was a long time regardless,
you know,
it's been great.
So I thank everybody and I'll see you in
a month,
but I will see earlier on h three and.
Well,
what can you say,
man,
what can you say other than this?
Love you guys love you guys and uh,
have a great holiday and go celebrate
papa bless.
Take some time off and enjoy.
Enjoy,
man.
All right,
we'll be seeing you guys real soon.
Thanks for watching.